on march 15 2011 martin sims was
wandering down the streets of carson
california his clothes were ragged he
was filthy and jibbering like a madman
with a full beard and long unkempt hair
his body was covered in scars but he
showed no signs of malnutrition what
made martin's sudden appearance so
remarkable he'd been missing for three
years when he was interviewed by police
they asked him where he'd been all this
time they couldn't believe his answer
he'd been trapped in an ikea since 2008
but this was no ordinary ikea this was a
dangerous anomaly that would come to be
known as
scp-3008 martin's strange answers in his
interview were laughed off by his
interviewing officers who assumed he was
either crazy or under the influence of
something but they caught the attention
of an scp foundation field agent
embedded in the precinct the report was
passed up the chain to a local site
director who approved a detachment of
foundation field operatives to look into
martin's case while he was reluctant to
lead the foundation agents back to the
offending ikea the foundation can be
extremely persuasive his screams of
please i'm banging you don't take me
back don't make me go back were noted
but ultimately disregarded when the scp
foundation had triangulated the position
of scp-3008 which was indeed an active
ikea the entire retail zone was closed
and barricaded under the pretense of a
severe black mold infestation armed
foundation personnel also arrived on the
site shortly after based on martin's
vague statements that there were
creatures of some kind inside due to his
deteriorating mental health martin was
unable to provide a great deal of lucid
information on the specific traits of
scp-3008
but one phrase he kept repeating was
bigger on the inside once researchers
were satisfied that martin had delivered
all the pertinent information he was
able to he was administered foundation
amnesty to erase his memory of the last
three years and return to his family a
cover story was formulated martin had
been kidnapped and abused for three
years by a mentally unbalanced stalker
in downtown carson he'd been able to
escape as said stalker took his own life
out of guilt a suicide that the
foundation expertly fabricated to make
their cover story airtight with the
loose end of martin sims taken care of
the true observation of scp-3008 could
begin a base set around the perimeter of
the mysterious ikea kept a 24-hour watch
on the building covering all potential
entrances and exits no exploratory
missions had yet been approved by the
foundation ethics committee so they
first wanted to perform a week of
external observation to see if any of
the store's anomalous properties
extended beyond the confines of the
building after a week of nothing it
appeared they did not a local site
director approved of the use of 20
disposable class-d personnel to explore
the interior of scp-3008 the d-class
operatives would be split into four
squads of five men alpha bravo charlie
and delta squad each would be assigned a
different quadrant of the store and
would deliver information back to the
control team on site via a live audio
and video link three of the four teams
upon entering the store reported nothing
out of the ordinary neither the audio or
video they were sending back indicated
anything different from a standard ikea
store from the flat pack wardrobes to
the swedish meatballs team delta however
suddenly began experiencing a scrambled
audio and video connection shortly after
communication with team delta dropped
off entirely they disappeared somewhere
inside the store and haven't been seen
since with one notable exception after
the disappearance and the extraction of
teams foundation researchers classified
scp-3008 as euclid because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the
interior of the store and even then
seemingly not the entire interior the
anomalous area within scp-3008 became
known as scp-3008-1
and containment appeared to be 100
secure there was no telling how many
people had already gone missing in the
store over the years but the
disappearances must be stopped the
foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of
scp-3008 but it appeared they could
prevent any further incidents by simply
preventing other civilians from
accessing the ikea store martin's
ravings about monsters were assumed to
just be the product of delirium until a
surviving member of delta teams suddenly
reappeared the date was november 3rd
2011 it was a cold night a few hours
after what would have been closing time
if the store were still active and seven
months after the extraction teams had
disappeared somewhere in the confines of
scp-3008 there had been no anomalous
activity outside the store since the
perimeter was first secured and the
foundation researchers hadn't expected
that to change until the last surviving
member of delta team came barging out of
the store's entrance startled field
operatives were amazed to see him again
but they were even more amazed to see
what was following him out of the store
repeating the same phrase the store is
now closed please exit the building
despite the fact that the entity chasing
the delta team survivor was wearing the
yellow shirt and blue pants of an ikea
store employee the being definitely was
not human it was around seven feet tall
with no visible face the entity had
grossly extended limbs with each arm
being around five or six feet long and
ending in a huge oversized hand the
whole process was so sudden that the
field agents present at the perimeter
weren't able to save the delta team
survivor as the entity reached forward
with his freakishly long arms grabbed
him and twisted his head off like a
child with a doll the field operative's
present drew their weapons and peppered
the entity with bullets it would later
be classified as
scp-3008-2 the being appeared to
collapse and die from the physical
trauma at which point it and the body of
the former delta team survivor were
taken for an autopsy by foundation
researchers there were no biological
abnormalities of the body of the delta
team survivor so it did not appear that
the anomalous properties of
scp-3008-1 had any effect on the
physiology of its occupants he was not
malnourished despite being missing for
months and the contents of his stomach
looked to be half-digested food
consistent with the menu of a typical
ikea store restaurant
scp-3008-2 on the other hand raised a
number of perplexing biological
questions the autopsy revealed that the
creature's clothes were actually part of
its body like an additional layer of
skin the creature lacked blood or any
kind of vascular system even stranger
the entity didn't appear to have bones
or internal organs not even a brain or
nervous system it was a being made
entirely of skin all the way to its core
how it was able to move or even live for
that matter remains a mystery though
when he worked for the scp foundation
you learn to accept that some things
will always remain unexplained one thing
was certain though martin sims was right
about his monsters after the incident
with delta team the foundation deemed
that sending manned explorations into
the heart of scp-3008 was too much of a
liability and planned a series of
drone-based reconnaissance missions into
the anomaly the first of these drones
experienced connection issues and failed
when attempting to venture into the
ikea's anomalous zone however after a
lengthy period of trial and error the
foundation was able to establish a more
secure connection with its drones even
went deep into the
scp-3008-1 anomalous zone it was only
then that some of the most extraordinary
discoveries were made
scp-3008-1 seemed to break the laws of
spatial reality as the area of the
ikea's interior was at least an order of
magnitude larger than its exterior just
as martin seems it said it was bigger on
the inside but just how much bigger the
foundation has yet to find evidence of
any physical terminators within the
store that might indicate
scp-3008-1 has an end point while an
area of at least 10 kilometers squared
has been uncovered in scp-3008-1
it could in theory be infinite laser
rangefinder tests which are normally
very reliable have only given
inconclusive results interestingly the
anomalous area doesn't have any clear
visual differences from the rest of the
ikea store except that it extends
forever an individual trapped within the
confines of
scp-3008-1 wouldn't even realize they've
entered an anomalous zone until they
tried to locate an exit and leave at
which point they'd find they were
already hopelessly lost the geography of
scp-3008-1 does at least appear to be
consistent so people trapped within are
theoretically able to retrace their
steps and escape if they haven't already
ventured too deep according to data
collected during the drone
reconnaissance missions
scp-3008-2 of which there appear to be a
vast population would wander the stores
aimlessly during the day they are
unresponsive to the drone's presence and
did not appear to be aggressive while
the physical descriptions of these
creatures could vary slightly they all
followed the same overall trend clothes
consistent with an ikea uniform no face
either seemingly too tall or too short
and limbs that are grossly out of
proportion with their bodies as the
foundation began sending drones deeper
into
scp-3008-1 they found another incredible
discovery there was an unknown
population of humans trapped inside
ikea's anomalous zone and these people
had used the ikea furniture around them
to create entire settlements and towns
within the store there were several of
these towns all of which seemed to
cohabitate peacefully even foundation
personnel found this development in
their research to be truly extraordinary
since scp-3008 was first identified
there have been only 14 civilian escapes
some had been trapped inside for months
others had been in there for years some
far longer than martin's three-year
stint while every one of these escapees
has eventually been released back to
their home after a liberal application
of amnestics and a proper cover story
has been devised the foundation
interviewed each of them extensively
first according to each of these
escapees the people trapped inside the
ikea have built an entirely new society
across the various settlements contrary
to the lord of the flies expectations of
a group of people isolated and afraid
there is immense cooperation between the
trapped civilians the food in the
several ikea restaurants in scp-3008
mysteriously replenishes while nobody's
there so there's no threat of starving
and the automatic turning on and off of
the lights forms as a rudimentary kind
of day and night cycle night time
however is when things get dangerous as
the
scp-3008-2 entities which are known to
the people inside as the staff become
extremely hostile after dark aggressive
hordes of the staff swarmed the
settlements at night repeating this door
is now closed please exit the building
the civilians inside are usually able to
repel these attacks with minimal
casualties but the constant war of
attrition slowly wears down those inside
the bodies of the creatures also need to
be removed from the area after each
attack as the presence of corpses or
even parts of corpses has been known to
heighten the ferocity of the next
night's attack during the day the staff
return to a docile and unresponsive
state though they'll still defend
themselves violently if anyone dares to
attack over the course of the interviews
with the 14 escapees foundation
researchers were able to answer another
of their key questions how had so many
people gone missing in the store for so
long without being noticed but the
answer they received only raised many
more unsettling queries according to the
escapees there were people inside the
settlements that despite being otherwise
of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence seem to lack very common
knowledge that even a child should know
for example some of them weren't aware
of the international space station
orbiting the earth or stranger still the
existence of the statue of liberty this
led the researchers to a frightening
conclusion
scp-3008-1 may not only be a nexus point
of multiple ikea stores in our dimension
it could be connected to ikeas in every
dimension where ikeas exist while it
only abducts a handful of people from
each store over an extended period of
time it suddenly becomes clear how this
scp was able to trap so many people
without detection over such a long
period of time which in turn led to an
even more terrifying revelation the scp
foundation may not have scp-3008-1
as contained as they thought it might
even be tucked away in an ikea store
somewhere near you just waiting for you
to visit after all there's always room
for one more
there are some things human beings
aren't meant to know and it's the sworn
duty of the scp foundation to discover
and contain such information but
sometimes knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the foundation itself to its
very core one such discovery occurred on
april 28 2016. that night
scp-2935 made itself known to the
foundation personnel to this day the
exact nature of scp-2935
is a mystery that even the foundation's
brightest minds can't completely
understand everything we know about
scp-2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous zone's
interior this is the story of those
infamous expeditions the nightmare began
around 5 am when scp foundation site 81
in bloomingdale indiana intercepted a
distorted radio signal communications
personnel at the site traced this
strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of joppa indiana
near u.s interstate 70. as is foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned cemetery the most recent death
on any of the tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago all the
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped limestone cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from the grass was dead there were no
trees no shrubs no animals or birds in
the sky they weren't looking at our
world they were looking at a strange
reflection of our world on the other
side of the cave in fact it wasn't a
cave at all it was a passageway between
two dimensions it was
scp-2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the scp foundation and the national
government one or more of our sites is
experiencing a communication breakdown
likely due to a containment breach of
unknown magnitude all citizens are
ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
april 20th 2016 until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
source site 81 but not this site-81 the
scp foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site-81 commands to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the potential
threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force epsilon 13 codenamed manifest
destiny to perform the first of three
manned missions into the heart of the
anomalous zone the first exploratory
mission into
scp-2935 was codenamed gauntlet and
consisted of a four-man team fitted with
full hazmat suits and direct video and
audio links to mission command the team
was led by a field operative known only
as agent juno his subordinates were
agents kale devon and underwood their
directive was to gather samples and
survey the area position directly around
the insertion point meaning the other
cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of their
lives after a 15-minute trek through the
cave manifest destiny arrived in the
mirror dimension where they were struck
by the eerie silence of a place that
seemed identical and yet so different
from their home dimension the first
observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation trees
grass weeds everything it was all dead
on orders from their superiors back in
the original dimension that we'll refer
to from here on as dimension prime
manifest destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of scp-2935
they traveled two kilometers without
detecting a single sign of plant or
animal life not even insects eventually
they came upon a farmhouse with two cars
parked outside with authorization from
command manifest destiny breached the
house and headed inside agent kale
confirmed that there was still power
flowing to the building as the lighting
appeared to work just fine but they came
upon a horrifying discovery in the
house's dining room three adult corpses
two female one male were seated at the
table a fourth corpse that of a male
child was sprawled out on the ground
nearby as if the death of what looked to
be an entire family wasn't awful enough
the manifest destiny team noticed a
number of other alarming details there
were no signs of decomposition on the
bodies nor did there appear to be any
obvious cause of death the family's last
meal was still on the table chicken
mashed potatoes and green beans while
the food looked cold and stale there was
no evidence of rot or spoiling the team
found an open newspaper dated april 19
2016 illustrating that the family may
have died a full eight days before the
discovery in dimension prime decay would
already be very well underway by that
point yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that manifest destiny collects samples
of the food as well as hair skin and
fluids from the corpses for further
study small electronics like smartphones
were also taken from the bodies agent
devon turned on the television in the
living room and found that while most
stations were now running test signals
the shopping channel was still live well
the feed was live at least both hosts
sat in front of the cameras dead but
perfectly preserved the date on the
screen read april 28 2016 suggesting
that the times of dimension prime and
mirror dimension were exactly the same
in fact everything seemed the same the
only difference between the two
dimensions being that some kind of
mysterious apocalyptic event had
occurred in the last eight days in
scp-2935's mirror dimension but exactly
what had happened or how remained a
mystery when manifest destiny exited the
farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them at this point the team returned to
the insertion point of scp-2935
but were instructed to remain in the
mirror dimension while additional units
joined them inside manifest destiny
swelled to 16 members with the notable
addition of agent roy as the new
commanding field officer the team split
into two groups of eight and agent roy
and his men infiltrated the mirror
dimension site-81 while agent juno's
detachment attempted to access the
base's off-site deep storage servers
this second expedition was codenamed
overland and led the foundation's field
agents even deeper into the terrifying
mystery of
scp-2935 accessing the site was easy for
roy's detachment it seemed there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious extinction event
in the distance fire still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to
have just dropped out of the sky agent
roy and his team like all scp foundation
personnel were fitted with vitals
trackers and they assumed that the
distress signal that started this whole
thing could have been triggered by the
deaths of every member of the foundation
at once in the mirror universe once
inside site 81 they realized that the
assumption was probably right going door
to door in the administrative wing they
found the perfectly preserved corpses of
everyone they knew to be stationed there
in dimension prime people who were
without a doubt still alive in their
universe samples from the corpses that
the foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in the
decomposition process had died with it
in scp-2935
death was total and absolute across all
types of life forms as agent roy's team
ventured further into the bowels of
site-81 they made another unsettling
discovery their own corpses in roughly
the same spots they'd been inside
dimension prime site 81 8 days prior
some of the foundation's top scientists
including the esteemed dr bright were
also found dead inside the facility in
an attempt to see just how far this
unexplained phenomenon stretched agent
roy's team decided to inspect the
containment cells where they found that
all the mirror universe's scps including
scp-2996 were dead in his desperation to
find some kind of exception to the
extinction event agent roy revealed a
terrifying secret to the rest of his
team
scp-682 the immortal misantropic lizard
and one of the deadliest creatures known
to the scp foundation was contained at
this very facility right below them
could it have something to do with what
was going on here they descended into
the containment facility to discover an
even more unsettling truth scp-682 the
unkillable anomaly floated dead in its
tank death truly made no exceptions
within scp-2935
agent roy's team left the site and
rendezvoused with agent juno's team to
send their research back to dimension
prime using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another manned operation codenamed 19.
they had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3 am while
underground in scp-2935
site 81 the team accidentally activated
the base's on-site nuclear weapon a
fail-safe meant to be detonated in the
case of an emergency containment breach
due to the base's fail-safe protocols
every member of the manifest destiny
team was locked and sealed inside
site-81 they along with everything else
were incinerated in the nuclear blast
once again the mirror universe inside of
scp-2935
was lifeless but that isn't where it
ends when the automated drones returned
out of the scp-2935
cave to the field operations in
dimension prime they were in for their
own horrifying discovery none of the
footage or information gathered from
scp-2935
illuminated how or why the extinction
event occurred everyone and everything
simply dropped dead at the exact same
moment nobody was aware nobody was
prepared death came suddenly and
silently and none were spared all the
foundation on dimension prime were left
with was a message from one of the
agents from manifest destiny agent
keller his final message was i don't
have any answers i don't think there are
any i'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us i'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site-81 it was a message from keller
himself but not the keller from universe
prime in this message keller described
the foundation in the mirror universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did a few days
earlier from a cave in joppa when he and
the others were dispatched inside they
discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar to the foundation command
but there was a key difference this
wasn't the mirror dimension they'd just
been studying but a third entirely
different dimension in his haunting
final words mirror dimension keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror to mention keller believed this
was the specter of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history had repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass from
dimension to dimension and our dimension
was the next in line the deaths of
manifest destiny may have saved our
entire universe as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to
bring death itself back with them the
foundation decided in the end to follow
keller's advice they sealed the entrance
to scp-2935 with concrete and now kept
it under constant watch since what waits
behind the barrier is an entity even
they have no power to stop if it ever
got through after all it had killed them
all before or at least another version
of them what's one more dimension on the
pile why it may now just seem like a
simple slab of concrete under an
abandoned cemetery this is why
scp-2935 might be the most dangerous scp
of all
a month ago dr robert maxwell was a
senior researcher working at the
facility but a tragic mistake had cost
the lives of several of his
co-researchers now he was being led down
a bleak hallway in armed biocontainment
area 14 a rifle wielding guard flanking
him on either side the once rising
researcher had a very different title
now
d8724
he had been made a d-class personnel
a death sentence
however as the guards led him to his
possible demise he wasn't dressed in the
typical d-class orange jumpsuit no he
was dressed in frilly rococo dining wear
more typical of 18th century france if
anything dr maxwell looked like he was
on his way to meet royalty and in a
sense he was
the former researcher had begged for any
other assignment but the site director
insisted on committing dr maxwell to
t-time with
scp-082
he'd always been the talkative type so
the two would make a perfect pairing and
if the creature found him sufficiently
amusing then maxwell might even leave
the containment cell alive
he had heard legends of the giant
creature they called the cannibal
maxwell hoped they were just stories
dr maxwell was pushed by the guards into
a large luxuriously appointed room and
the doors were locked behind him he felt
like a child surrounded by freakishly
large furniture and 10-foot high
ceilings the fog of obnoxious floral
perfumes couldn't fully cover up the
pervasive smell of death that lingered
in the cavernous halls of 082's palace
thanks to an elaborate ruse conducted by
the foundation
scp-082 believed he was the king of
france and that his containment cell was
a palace where he remained for his own
safety the creature's continued good
behavior and everyone else's safety
relied on visitors keeping up that lie
maxwell had never worked in this area of
the facility so a lot of the standard
procedures were new to him still his
superior had given him a clear directive
talk to the monster communicate with him
be cordial and friendly see if you can
find out more about his mysterious past
and most importantly if you want to
survive
don't annoy him the down on his luck
scientist gulped inside trying to steady
his nerves in this oversized fake french
palace
he just kept thinking surely he can't be
that big he almost talked himself into
believing that the accounts of the
creature were just that tall tales until
a huge figure began lumbering into the
main chamber it was him
scp-082
also known as fernand the cannibal
scp-082 was an eight-foot tall hulking
monster built sturdier than the castles
it likes to imagine are its true home
swollen bloated and grossly out of
proportion the creature clocks in at
over 700 pounds
most of which is pure muscle that's
almost impossible to pierce with
conventional weaponry
scp-082 stopped just feet away and
stared at dr maxwell with its beady
sunken in eyes like a hungry rat
just the sight of it struck terror into
dr maxwell's heart but he didn't dare
show his fear
instead he remembered his brief training
bowing politely and forcing a smile
referring to the creature as your
highness
and profusely thanking it for granting
him an audience the monster continued
staring without saying anything and then
gave a wide lock-jawed grin
showing off its huge teeth it did
everything through gritted teeth except
eat and sing
dr maxwell hoped he wouldn't be a part
of either activity
fernand gave a low booming chuckle he
thanked dr maxwell for coming to give
him some company and invited him to come
further inside and take a seat adding
with a sly wink that he won't buy
the monster complained that he so rarely
gets visitors to the palace these days
but he omitted the fact that the main
reason for this was his tendency to
devour them
maxwell nodded and followed the giant
deeper into its oversized abode he
couldn't help but notice that the
monster's arms looked like huge fleshy
punching bags he knew that if fernand
wanted to he could easily crush him flat
just like he'd done to so many
unfortunate guards during containment
breaches
fernand told dr maxwell that he was
thinking of having some decorating work
done the walls of his palace were
starting to look awfully drab and he
gestured to one covered with a rusty red
streak maxwell remembered that d-class
cleaners were sent into the containment
cell twice a month to tidy any of
ferdinand's messes but they often ended
up becoming one of the messes themselves
the creature encouraged maxwell to take
a seat at his oversized dining table
while he tended to a pot of what he said
was full of delicious onion soup maxwell
obliged his host's request and took a
seat at a huge chair that made him look
like a six-year-old sitting at the
grown-ups table meanwhile ferdinand was
using a huge machete-like knife to
cleave onions in half for his bubbling
pot of stew even though ferdinand had
shown no signs of outward aggression as
he watched the cannibal hack away at
onions with his enormous knife maxwell
could feel himself beginning to sweat
after all they didn't call this creature
the cannibal for nothing this was a
monster with a truly horrifying body
count during previous containment
breaches it had taken enough
tranquilizer to put down two elephants
to subdue the creature but not before
multiple agents quite literally lost
their heads in the process
fernan was able to bite them off with
one huge chomp like he was eating a
drumstick snapping right through the
bone with his incredible tooth and jaw
strength surprisingly when he wasn't on
a violent rampage foundation researchers
had found
scp-082 to be unusually polite and
forthcoming offering the researchers
plenty of information about himself and
his past
the only problem was that almost
everything the creature said was a
complete lie
from his time as a researcher maxwell
knew that there were only a few details
about the creature that could be
ascertained for certain
scp-082 would reliably answer to the
name fernand and genetically ferdinand
was technically human
the means by which ferdinand became so
grotesquely huge strong and
cannibalistic are still unknown
foundation personnel are still looking
into whether it's due to some kind of
anomalous genetic mutation or by more
supernatural means
all we know is that he's big
unpredictable and extremely dangerous
dr robert maxwell sat terrified at the
dining table of scp-082
listening to fernand's slightly dull
blade chopped through the final onion
which he then tossed into the boiling
soup
fernand had switched the topic of
conversation to one of his favorite
fictional characters
hannibal lecter
of course hannibal the cannibal isn't
quite so fictional to fernan while he's
been shown to be extremely intelligent
in terms of puzzle solving and memory he
seems to have no understanding of the
distinctions between fiction and reality
he assumes all movies and tv shows are a
form of documentary or reality
television and ever since seeing the
silence of the lambs ferdinand has been
eager to meet with dr lecter which he
emphasized to maxwell over and over
since trying to explain the concept of
fiction to ferdinand had never
previously worked maxwell simply told
him that dr lecter is extremely busy at
the moment but will visit whenever he
gets a chance this seemed to satisfy
fernan who placed two large bowls of
steaming soup on the table before
sitting down a little too close to
maxwell he couldn't help but notice that
the giant cannibal was now sitting
within biting distance and as a lowly
d-class nobody would be rushing in to
save him if things went south
fernand began ranting through his
clenched teeth once more occasionally
stopping to consume a hefty spoonful of
onion soup maxwell was sure to do the
same not wanting to seem anything less
than polite but soon the tenor of
ferdinand's rant began to shift
typically the monster spoke french or
heavily accented english
now he was affecting the accent of a
victorian gentleman peppering his speech
with telly ho and the game is afoot
maxwell was confused at first but
quickly realized the game fernand was
playing it's well known that fernan is a
pathological liar who likes to play
numerous characters
changing his mannerisms and clothes
accordingly these personas have included
a vampire big bird andre the giant
foundation researcher dr bright the
incredible hulk alexander the great
captain hook dr frankenstein and
frankenstein's monster and of course in
this case
the iconic fictional detective sherlock
holmes
fearing for his life in this strange
situation dr maxwell did the only thing
he could
play along as fernand reeled off his
holmesian delusions maxwell began to
play the role of dr john watson asking
follow-up questions and complimenting
ferdinand's impeccable deductive
reasoning and it seemed to be working
ferdinand played along too acting as
though the two of them really were
arthur conan doyle's crime-fighting duo
towards the end of their game dr maxwell
was even starting to enjoy it
amazed that his quick thinking was
actually keeping him safe but just then
the cannibal froze as if in a trance he
locked eyes with dr maxwell like a mad
dog that you can't tell if it's going to
bite you or not he saw the creature's
gargantuan teeth separating its huge
jaws stretching open
this could surely only mean one thing dr
maxwell winced and prepared for death
cursing that all of his quick thinking
had amounted to nothing
fernan leaned towards him his gaping maw
with its hot onion scented breath just
inches away from maxwell
and then he began to sing the cannibal
broke into a raucous victorian pub song
happy and jovial in his moment of terror
dr maxwell had forgotten that this was
the other reason
scp-082 opens his nightmarish jaws
relief washed over him as he knew he was
safe at least for the moment
not long after foundation guards arrived
and escorted him from the cell leaving
the delusional giant to his own device's
back in the so-called palace
the former researcher had done it he had
bested ferdinand the cannibal and
hopefully it would be the last time he'd
ever be face to face with that deranged
giant
unfortunately for dr robert maxwell in a
performance review later that week one
of his superiors remarked that fernand
enjoyed his company and he had done a
great job such a good job in fact that
ferdinand insisted he have dr maxwell
for dinner
or any other meal for that matter
sometime
very soon
the first thing that tipped the
foundation off to
scp-087's presents were the reports of
numerous unexplained disappearances on
campus there were plenty of rumors about
what might be behind them but field
agents suspected that the true source of
the vanishing would be something beyond
civilian imagination all anyone knew for
sure was that everyone who had gone
missing was last seen in a certain
administrative building on the
university grounds and that the
disappearances only seemed to happen
when the elevator was out the campus was
soon flooded with foundation agents
creating a barrier around the
administrative building and the presumed
habitat of scp scp-087
nobody else could get in and hopefully
whatever was inside couldn't get out one
of the foundation's lead scientists was
flown in to consult on the investigation
what could have been behind those
students disappearing the doctor's
preliminary interviews with university
staff who worked in the building yielded
some interesting details strange noises
like banging and even a faint shrill
crying would be heard from a door that
led to a no longer used stairway in
hallway 3b staff in the building had no
reason to ever take these stairs
especially considering how many of them
reported a strange sense of a noise when
just standing outside the door the only
reason someone might take those stairs
is due to elevator malfunctions
in that instant the doctor had put it
all together the staff they interviewed
had their memory wiped with amnestics
special chemicals used by the foundation
with the power to delete human memories
the foundation only used them for staff
or civilians who had confirmed contact
with an scp and the doctor knew that
they had a live one on their hands
the staircase there was something
terribly wrong with that staircase and
it was the scp foundation's job to find
out what before it made anybody else
disappear this is the story of
scp-087 otherwise known as the endless
staircase and the three doomed journeys
down into its murky depths the doctor
was more than eager to begin research
into the staircase and its frightening
anomalous properties after all you don't
claw your way up to being one of the
foundation's key researchers without
being brave and perhaps just a little
bit deranged as with standard once a
perimeter was secured around the
staircase the good doctor requested a
selection of d-class personnel for
testing for those not in the know
d-class is the foundation's polite way
of saying cannon fodder
the doctor would send three d-class
prisoners for use in his investigation
of scp-087
the first
d-8432 was according to official
documentation on the incident a
43-year-old male of average build and
appearance and unremarkable
psychological background this man once
worked for the foundation in a more
official capacity but he was given the
often deadly demotion to d-class due to
a dangerous mistake handling
scp-682 that led to the deaths of
several other agents now
it looked like it would be his turn the
doctor explained his mission to him
explore the staircase gather data help
us find out exactly what we're dealing
with here if you come back alive there
may even be a promotion in it for you
and with that promise d8432 was given
his loadout a 75 watt flood lamp with
battery power capable of lasting 24
hours an audio headset and a handheld
camcorder fitted with a transmission
stream and an audio headset that would
allow him to communicate with dr bright
d-8432 was then pushed through the door
in hallway 3b and out onto the staircase
according to declassified foundation
files describing the staircase
scp-087 is an unlit platform staircase
stairs descend on a 38 degree angle for
13 steps before reaching a semicircular
platform of approximately 3 meters in
diameter descent direction rotates 180
degrees at each platform the design of
scp-087 limits subjects to a visual
range of approximately 1.5 flights but
in d8432's mind unlit really didn't seem
like the right word he would have chosen
all-consuming darkness despite carrying
a powerful 75 watt lamp d8432 was only
capable of partially lighting the
platform he was standing on and the
illumination only stretched down 9 of
the 13 steps to the next platform
when d8432 observed how little help his
lamp was giving him he was instructed to
shine it out of the doorway into hallway
3b when he did so the light seemed to
shine far further than it ever could in
scp-087
already the beginning of the anomalous
activity was obvious everywhere else
darkness is just the absence of light in
scp-087 darkness eats light it was like
a tangible black mass that only a
certain amount of light could survive
while the rest just wouldn't show d8432
swallowed hard over a lump in his throat
the door to hallway 3b was closed behind
him and he was ordered to descend
surviving to see that promotion was
feeling unlikely but it's not like he
had a choice
if he tried to escape scp-087 before he
was permitted he'd be shot by scp
foundation field agents on the spot so
he followed the high-ranking doctor's
orders and began to descend the steps to
the next platform nothing about the
physical makeup of the staircase itself
seemed abnormal the base and walls were
a very plain dull concrete with a metal
handrail the only thing that seemed
unique about it so far was the strange
light bending properties and was until
he reached the second platform down and
he heard a soft echoing cry a child's
cry who was shrieks of panic or maybe
even pain echoing up from below he was
asked why he had stopped and he
explained the crying sound he'd been
hearing it sounded like it was coming
from far down the stairs maybe 200
meters below him he could just make out
the words please
health and down here coming from the
darkness but the team outside the
stairwell couldn't hear anything so they
asked him to descend further another
platform down and they could hear it too
the unmistakable cries of a terrified
child please help and down here d-8432
was ordered to keep going and only stop
if he noticed changes to the visual
environment or in the sounds he was
hearing
d8432 knowing his life was on the line
had to keep going and descended another
20 flights of stairs before stopping to
remark that the sounds of the child
hadn't gotten any closer they still
sounded just as far away as when he'd
first heard them he was told his
observations were noted and pressured to
continue within half an hour d8432 had
descended a full 50 floors with no sign
of a bottom in sight
somehow the volume of the child's crying
had remained consistent throughout as if
it was moving away from d8432 at the
same rate he was descending at this
point d8432 reported that he was feeling
uneasy the doctor said that this was
understandable given the circumstances
he'd been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire
time and something about the truly
bottomless nature of the staircase and
the ever elusive crying was undeniably
eerie but things were about to really
take a turn for the worst as d8432
stepped forward towards the next set of
stairs he froze there was something on
the platform below him barely
illuminated by the light of his 75 watt
it was a face vaguely human in size and
shape but with a few terrifying
differences it had grayish skin and no
mouth nostrils or pupils and yet da432
could feel that this thing was making
eye contact with him he couldn't move
trapped in the thing's piercing gaze in
an instant the face jerked forwards
suddenly only about a foot away from
d432's face eyes staring into its own
d8432 screamed and ran scaling all 50
flights in an astonishing 18 minutes
before charging out into hallway 3b
there he collapsed from the exhaustion
and the fear of what he'd just seen
upon reviewing the footage the strange
face was designated scp-087-1
fascinating it was time for a second
experiment the doctor just had to know
more the second test subject was d-9035
a 28-year-old male with a history of
aggravated assaults against women he was
given the same loadout as his
predecessors except this time with an
even more powerful 100 watt bulb he was
also given 100 small led lights that had
adhesive backs and a battery life of
approximately three weeks with which
they intended to permanently illuminate
scp-087
however despite the extra wattage of his
bulb he still couldn't illuminate beyond
the ninth step
scp-087 wouldn't allow it having no
ideas of the horrors that lurked below
him he descended on the doctor's orders
and began fixing the leds to the walls
of each platform he passed the led
always illuminated the landing but the
light couldn't pass the first step on
either side the flights of stairs
themselves would remain in perpetual
darkness after the second flight
d-9035 noticed the same crying d8432 had
heard and became uneasy just like before
as d-9035 descended the volume of the
crying didn't seem to increase as if for
every step he descended the source of
the crime descended one two keeping them
at a constant 200 meters apart
still he was ordered to continue his
descent and the placing of leds even as
his paranoia grew when he reached the
51st floor he observed damage to the
wall and steps sections appeared to have
been smashed to rubble by an extreme
force as he descended past the broken
step he only felt his fear anxiety and
paranoia grow
the doctor made note of the fact that
scp-087 seemed to cause instances of
anxiety and terror in its occupants even
before they encountered scp-087-1
as d-9035 reached platform 89 a full 350
meters under the initial platform he
stopped dead in his tracks and saw
something staring up at him from the
platform below that same terrible grey
face with those dead white eyes
he was encouraged to stay calm and try
to get better footage of the face but it
charged for him and d-9035 ran for his
life he ascended the staircase at a
staggering pace even passing out from
exhaustion and remaining motionless for
14 minutes halfway
when d-9035 finally gathered the
strength to get up he scrambled back to
hallway 3b and fell into a state of
catatonia he remains unresponsive to all
external stimuli to this day just
staring off into the distance with a
haunted expression almost like he's
still there in the hallway the doctor
wanted to conduct one more test before
he ordered
scp-087 shut off from the world forever
and it was the most terrifying of all
the final subject was d-9884
a 23-year-old woman with a history of
depression and use of excessive force
the doctor had hoped that d-9884 would
travel the deepest yet and so he gave
her the additional supplies of a
backpack containing 3.75 liters of water
15 nutrient bars and one thermal blanket
as far as the foundation was concerned
she was in this for the long haul but
none of them had any idea quite how
right they were
when d-9884 entered scp-087
all the lights from the previous
expedition had disappeared still she was
ordered to go deeper
she heard the crying of the mysterious
child if it was even a child at all and
again she was ordered to go deeper at
the 496th landing even as dean 9884
seemed to slip into a state of mortal
terror
once again she was ordered to go even
deeper
every moment he was hoping to get a
better look at the face of scp-087-1
and when d-9884 finally broke and fled
back upstairs he did the face appeared
but this time it was mere inches behind
her staring directly into the camera
with its blank eyes startling even this
veteran of the supernatural the face
appearing caused dean 9884 to panic and
flee but instead of going back up the
stairs to safety she went deeper down
the staircase in an attempt to escape it
deeper and deeper and deeper until her
video feed cut out d-9884 was never seen
again in the aftermath of the tests the
scp was classified as euclid it may have
been dangerous but at least it was easy
to contain the door to hallway 3b was
replaced with one made out of reinforced
steel with an electro release lock
mechanism it has been disguised to
resemble a janitorial closet consistent
with the rest of the building the lock
won't release unless a classified number
of electrical volts are applied while
the key is turned counterclockwise and
after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the
door staff at the building never again
reported hearing strange noises as for
the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of
scp-087
we may never know but one can only
assume it isn't pleasant
a tangled mass of yarn and ribbon sounds
more like what you'd find in the back
room of a craft store or a forgotten
closet than a mysterious creature worthy
of investigation and yet that's exactly
what
scp-066 appeared to be or at least it
did at first glance but the scp
foundation doesn't contain and study
just anything and there was and still is
something incredibly strange just below
the surface of scp-066
also known as eric's toy at first eric's
toy seemed to be completely harmless and
even helpful a knot of string that
produced strange but harmless items and
effects but the foundation soon
discovered a dark side to scp-066
while it may be referred to as a toy
this is no mere play thing
scp-066 weighs only about one kilogram
and appears to be a braided bunch of
yarn and ribbon though there is no
apparent musical capability within the
strands of yarn and ribbon themselves
music can be produced by moving
individual strands one at a time when it
was first being studied this scp was
composed of multi-colored strings and
ribbons but it has since undergone a
transformation and now presents an
appearance somewhat different from its
initial description the strands of yarn
and ribbon can be used to play the notes
of a diatonic scale c d e f g a b though
the research has not been able to
determine just how
scp-066 produces music or any sound at
all
scp-066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066-2
its classification was adjusted to a
sub-category of euclid euclid impetus
euclid is a classification given to scps
that are more difficult to contain than
those classified as safe impetus in
latin means attack and specifies that
scp-066 is not only euclid class but on
the more aggressive side while 066 is
not always aggressive towards humans the
events of incident 066-2 prove that it
is highly unpredictable and should not
be provoked like many scps it proved
that underestimating its capabilities
can be a dangerous mistake before the
incident
scp-066 displayed only charming if
unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strings
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hostility and went about
their work with a lighthearted carefree
spirit after playing an improvised
six-note melody with the strands a
researcher was thrilled to find that
scp-066 was capable of shape-shifting
its appearance changed to resemble a
small calico kitten for 17 minutes the
kitten was incredibly friendly rubbing
its head against the researcher's glove
hand and purring loudly ironically
enough the kitten also spent time
playing with a piece of string after the
17 minutes were up the kitten
transformed back into
scp-066's original form a few days later
another researcher played a different
melody on the strands and was surprised
to find that when they stopped the music
continued on its own the sound of an
acoustic guitar kicked in accompanied by
vocals with no visible source for either
sound the scp then played a four-minute
song with lyrics warning against the use
of sharp objects without the supervision
of a parent especially scissors after
the song ended the scp was silent for
the rest of the day the following week a
research assistant used the strands of
scp-066 to play the opening notes of
happy birthday and a chocolate cupcake
with a lit birthday candle appeared from
within the braided strings
against the warning of his peers the
assistant ate the cupcake in response
the scp played the rest of happy
birthday and the assistant suffered no
adverse effects from the cupcake
all of this fun was brought to a swift
end when one scientist suggested that a
portion of
scp-066's yarn body be cut off and
removed so that the specimen could be
tested
on april 18 2008 the event that would
become known as incident 066-2 took
place
a young man known only as d066-4437
or d was assigned to the task
naturally he was a member of the highly
disposable d-class personnel but dee was
grateful for the opportunity as most
experiments of a similar nature involved
quite a bit more obvious risk it was a
simple enough job take a pair of
scissors snip off some yarn and bring it
back to the lab for further study
it was hardly on the level of
supervising 173 or being 682's latest
chew toy
he entered the containment room where
scp-066 was lying dormant and still and
approached it with scissors he grabbed a
small handful of string and started to
cut as soon as the scissors began to cut
through the fabric the scp rolled out of
his grasp it came to a stop one meter
away where it started to make a
high-pitched squeaking sound resembling
the cry of a frightened rabbit unsure
what to do and unprepared for this
scenario d approached the entity again
he snagged another fistful of yarn and
cut only for 066 to curl into a ball and
roll away from him again even faster
this time once it was safely on the
other side of the room and away from the
scissors it stopped moving only this
time it didn't squeak instead for the
very first time since its containment it
spoke in a deep uncannily human voice
and asked
are you eric after recovering from his
initial shock at hearing a voice come
out of a massive string he responded no
i'm not this answer set something off in
scp-066
and its form began to shift and change
the string wriggled around on the floor
unbraiding and wrapping around itself
into a mound the colors previously a
rainbow of shades shifted until every
strand was a blood red much to dee's
horror the transformation was not yet
complete small bumps began to emerge
from the spaces between the strands of
yarn popping out all over the bright red
mass if that wasn't terrifying enough
suddenly all together as one they
blinked open revealing themselves to be
over a dozen small eyes every single eye
was focused at d studying him staring
him down
scp-016 then began to produce loud
abrupt dissonant notes like someone
banging on the keys of a piano d had
seen enough he abandoned his task and
fled the containment room after this
failed attempt to extract a sample
scp-066's behavior and its treatment of
personnel who interacted with it began
to change dramatically before the
incident the scp was largely dormant
only becoming active if a melody was
played using its strands following the
incident and its change of form 066
began to move on its own long strands of
its yarn body would move like tentacles
writhing and wriggling around at high
speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the
sight of any human regardless of the
human's behavior the scp would begin to
react with sound and effect within six
seconds the first of these effects was
noted by a research assistant who
entered the scp's containment facility a
week after the incident with dee
as she approached 066 to take notes
about its current state and its new
ability to move a bee appeared out of
nowhere it stung the assistant and flew
away before it could be captured weeks
later a team of 11 personnel were
monitoring the scp when it suddenly
burst into a rendition of beethoven's
second symphony it produced this music
at a volume of over 140 decibels
permanently deafening three of the
personnel and causing permanent hearing
damage in the other aid it was theorized
that the scp did this as an act of
retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these personnel refused to
work with
scp-066 again when a new team was
assigned to monitor the entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room went dark and there
was a complete loss of visibility the
lights were unable to be turned on for
five hours and any attempt at an
alternate light source such as a
flashlight was unsuccessful it was as if
the darkness in the room swallowed any
and all light right up it was similar to
the oppressive darkness within scp-087
or the unlimited block of
scp-3001's shadow dimension the
personnel in the room later reported
hearing the sound of loud labor
breathing just behind their shoulders
though when they searched for a source
of the sound they could find nothing
there had been no recent anomalies
reported or any additional hostile
behavior instead whenever it sees a new
human
scp-066 repeats the name eric again and
again in the same deep voice
who is eric no one at the facility knows
or if they do they have not reported it
to any official channels it is possible
that the scp was once owned by someone
named eric and perhaps given the
circumstances under which
scp-066 first said the name eric
attempted to cut the threads of the
entity while it was in his care
unfortunately there are no official
records of how
scp-066 was discovered or why it was
brought to the foundation in the first
place its origins remain murky and as
mysterious as everything else about it
all that is known is that whoever eric
is scp-066
is determined to find him once the scp's
class was changed from safe to euclid
its containment procedures had to be
adjusted
while it was previously kept in a simple
room it is now contained in a tungsten
carbide box at its site's high value
item storage facility once a month the
box is inspected for damage to its
interior due to the scp's tendency to
use its appendages to wear down the
walls of the box over time
if there is any damage
scp-066 is to be moved to a new box
using a robotic arm that performs this
transfer in less than three seconds the
foundation has attempted to place
recording devices in the box with the
entity in order to monitor its behavior
when there are no humans present but the
scp destroys every recording device
placed inside of its containment box and
any attempts to record its behavior when
it is not being observed by humans have
been unsuccessful whatever it's doing
when there is no one around it wants to
keep a secret
on the surface
scp-066 is one of the less frightening
finds contained within the walls of the
scp foundation it does not have claws or
teeth or the ability to cause mass
deaths but it has incredible
unpredictable capabilities and seems
very capable of holding a grudge there
is so much that is unknown about it from
its origins to its form to its ability
to manifest matter from nothing and
there is something deeply unsettling
about this scp's unpredictable behavior
and increased hostility towards being
observed we do not know what it is done
and we do not know what it will do next
all we can do is wonder as we ponder the
nature of scp-066
it does nothing but sit staring with
unblinking eyes
waiting for eric to come back
an scp foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be especially when the scp you're
supposed to be studying is one that you
can't see the researcher is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next he can hear the sounds of
knives scraping behind of flesh sizzling
and searing from high heat he braces
himself as a burst of heat hits the back
of his head as if a fireball has erupted
an object floats through the air and
settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious it may surprise you to learn
that there is no rule that the scp
foundation must deal exclusively with
violent and vicious creatures not every
scp held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for humanity as
scp-682
or the world-ending threat posed by the
likes of scp-2317
some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the scp foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with scp-5031
as per the foundation's containment
procedures this quasi-humanoid meaning
it appears to have some vaguely human
features is held in an airtight cell
that is regularly checked by foundation
personnel on a bi-weekly basis scp-5031
has no need for regular nutrition or
regular interactions from staff the
trick with
scp-5031 is not being eaten by it since
though it doesn't need food it does
still hunt and consume anything it
encounters human or otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen but
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism
which is when observed it will literally
cease to exist
some might choose to refer to this as a
quantum lock however it is worth noting
that traces left by scp-5031
still remain observable when the
creature has temporarily disappeared for
example trails of blood and scratch
marks left behind by scp-5031 still
exists when the scp itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when scp-5031's
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creature's
physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced that scp-5031 levitates about
half a meter above ground level sports
an abnormally small necklace head atop
an elongated torso approximately 1.9
meters long
with three sets of spindly lower arms
that branch outwards using these arms
and its loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031
beyond its defensive capabilities and
apparent physical attributes
are the series of nine tests conducted
by senior researcher stanley huxtable
appalled by the conditions that the
creature was being kept in huxtable took
over the role of hcl supervisor for
scp-5031
having grown increasingly frustrated and
empathetic towards the creature
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit huxtable devised a
series of tests to introduce
scp-5031 to various different stimuli as
a way to better understand the creature
and hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering it's worth remembering that
the scp foundation makes its mission to
be cold not cruel in performing their
duties to protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a shelter
the first of huxtables tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging scp-5031 stress levels based on
how much it screamed when compared to
normal
huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
forest deep grotto and seaside paradise
ambience
as well as the best of late 60s british
rock band jethro tull however the best
of mozart enya kiss and ben folds
produced dramatically different results
decreasing
scp-5031's apparent stress following
this test senior researcher huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress-reducing effects of music on
scp-5031 seemed to decrease
but keeping the playlist on shuffles
seemed to keep the creature consistently
calmer than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second bowling ball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-53 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken's stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031 gently rolled a basketball
towards it but ceased any further
engagement after the chicken squawked
from being hit by the ball next to be
introduced into the enclosure was a
blindfolded d-class staff member who was
instructed to sit down and roll the
basketball towards scp-5031
after doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to cease the creature's
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxtable had another class d engage in a
game of catch with
scp-5031 while facing away from the
creature
this test proceeded successfully and
senior researcher huxtable remarked how
scp-5030 motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized lcd
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser
one display showed an image of a rock
and the other an image of a rotisserie
chicken after some brief probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
final phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain inactive unless
the creature spelled out the same word
with a collection of lettered blocks it
was provided with after some initial
confusion and frustrations as to why the
button would not dispense food when
pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received
senior researcher huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
dish pairings
later another class d
d52125 was introduced to
scp-5031's enclosure to aid in further
testing through
d52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its newfound friend d52125
researcher huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions
next a spice rack was placed inside the
creature's cell and d-52125 demonstrated
how to season mead this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices
using its letter blocks to request more
more more garlic powder interestingly
the creature only created artwork or
music when
d52125 was present but seemed to
thoroughly enjoy its experimentation
with food when left alone
following this development senior
researcher huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031
providing the creature with cooking
utensils and using
d52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown how
to prepare a variety of different dishes
from hamburgers and tacos to mongolian
beef steak clam chowder and profiteroles
in addition to a small peanut allergy
this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with d52125
even volunteering to be the first to
taste test 5031's dishes it was shortly
after this test that scp-5031
spoke its very first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxtable was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development
the final test almost seemed to be what
the creature was born for over the
course of two months
scp-5031 was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal
which would then be served to foundation
staff for thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
gordon ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric
next came a beautiful duck confit glazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped
generously with sweet cranberry compote
paired with a side of butternut squash
gnocchi and served on a bed of kale
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the exquisite meal was a
spiced cassava pie for dessert
complimented with the finest french
vanilla ice cream and a maple hazelnut
syrup
an scp-50-30 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxtable but
the entire foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's tale huxtable
reported that during the thanksgiving
banquet it had created
scp-5031 stress levels reduced entirely
new kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that
scp-5031 isn't simply just another
malicious malevolent monster that the
foundation has to keep under lock and
key for the safety of the world
instead
scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researchers stanley
huxtable and his fellow foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow
under the proud watch of researcher
huxtable
over 50 men and women clad in red robes
kneel before an unholy altar they chant
and mutter indecipherable words words of
cruelty and madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
accountants
this was before they fell under the
ungodly influence of a new ruler the
center of this makeshift place of
worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the beast they worship is
known to the scp foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their god all powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother marsh
walks among their crouched forms he
whispers instructions for the great day
of liberation that's soon to come
providing everyone plays their part it's
a plan months in the making and one that
if it goes off without a hitch could
free their monstrous god into the world
they would strike at the very heart of
their enemy the scp foundation
when they least expect it and nothing
shall stand in their way how could they
lose when they have a god on their side
but why did all these normal people
become violent zealots for a squid-faced
deity it all began with a dream to those
who experienced these dreams they felt
more like prophecies premonitions of the
glorious horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon
their tentacled god holding dominion
over all at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken and afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't
every night the nightmare would return
they'd see the images the red sky the
dead and enslaved the tentacled god
and after a while it would come to them
even when they weren't asleep
eventually happening whenever they
closed their eyes little by little this
scene stopped looking so hideous
and started to look
glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd gone insane
in their eyes they were safer than
they'd ever been
they finally had purpose they were
working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
ruler sent to them in their dreams they
worshiped together building altars and
idols to congregate around they perform
dark blood rituals involving human and
animal sacrifice it was when brother
marsh the anointed one arrived to guide
them towards their true mission that
things kicked into high gear
just three months prior brother marsh
had been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded his
thoughts with a simple message
free me and the new world i create shall
be your playground
since then he devoted himself completely
to the cause quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his
new life's purpose
infiltrating the scp foundation and
releasing his inhuman ruler from its
imprisonment
that was the single goal he united the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
god and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike
they'd finally gathered the necessary
intel to subvert the will of the most
powerful secret organization on earth
even the strongest institution is made
of people and people are weak unlike the
almighty tentacled god people
could be broken
the people in question were kelly
thompson sydney levitt jordan broche dr
juan gutierrez and jillian larson dr
juan gutierrez was a researcher with
level 3 clearance on the site where the
tentacled god was being contained sydney
levitt and jordan broche were both
security officers charged with verifying
personnel clearance on site kelly
thompson was a member of site
administration with research
authorization powers and jillian larson
was a research assistant who often
collaborated with dr gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to scp-2662
and bringing their plan to fruition
normally personnel dossiers on people
working for the foundation were highly
confidential but the devotees of the
tentacled god had their ways they had a
number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in
and pulling some basic information off
of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turned to some good
old-fashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results
of course while the colts grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous they
weren't stupid while gathering their
intel they also made sure to find out
what exactly they were up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
task force tau-9 better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping mall cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother marsha's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock tau9 had been charged with
tracking down any new
scp-2662 cults and dismantling them and
brother marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled god then they'd
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming force the
scp-2662 worshipers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their god
dr gutierrez was shot in the head while
he slept sidney levitt and jordan broche
were both stabbed to death before either
even realized what was happening
thompson who'd gotten up to use the
bathroom went down in the hail of
machine gun fire jillian larson had seen
that mask figures were breaking into her
home and attempted to flee but was
caught and beaten to death by cultists
in her hallway it was a strange irony
that people whose day jobs entailed
working with some of the most dangerous
and nightmarish anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing
more than regular humans
so far brother marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their journeys to the site where the
tentacled god was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
scp foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your coworkers and each one slip
neatly into position disappearing into
the familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled god
would be another thing entirely
that's where the rest of the cult would
come into play heavily armed with
whatever firearms they could get their
hands on the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on
in the ensuing chaos the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site
could take advantage of the distraction
and break into the containment chamber
it was perfect they launched their
attack from the outside and from within
when brother marsh declared that the
time was right the assault began
a legion of gun wielding cultists seemed
to spring out of nowhere and started
shooting up the warehouse that was a
front for the containment site the site
quickly mobilized guards and task force
members to take on the sudden threat and
just as brother marsh had anticipated
the site director called on the majority
of town nine to help repel the violent
cultists from their perimeter tau9
obeyed leaving three task force members
behind the guard
scp-2662's containment chamber
they expected to be guarding the cell
from rampaging religious zealots seeking
an audience with their god what they
didn't expect was a group of five
foundation employees walking right up to
them and opening fire killing two tau
nine members and taking the third as
hostage while the war was being waged
outside the infiltrators had found the
tentacle god's containment cell in the
low-risk humanoid war
their hostage insisted that using him
wouldn't give them any leverage the rest
of his team would neutralize the whole
group him included if that's what it
took to stop them the infiltrators
explained that using him as leverage was
never their intention he wasn't a
hostage at all
he was a sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662
twice as tall as a regular man with 10
huge tentacles emerging from its back in
their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators
what they certainly didn't expect was to
see the tentacled god hunched over a
computer screen still god's work in
mysterious ways so they stuck to the
plan and began chanting they pulled out
a sacrificial dagger and began
sacrificing their captured tao9 member
it was at this point that scp-2662
turned and saw what they were doing with
a look of pure horror he rose up from
his computer his headphones getting
caught as he did so he told them to go
away that he didn't want them here and
that the murdering people in his bedroom
like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their god accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong
they tried more chanting and painting
arcane symbols on the floor and blood
but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian god to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games
this was seriously not cool the cultists
were baffled they told the tentacled god
that they were there to free him he
replied that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultists
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town nine
stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down with surgical precision
the war outside was already over brother
marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the fire fight tao9 didn't
look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence unfortunately
they had to deal with an attempted cult
invasion every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent cults who relentlessly
track down and worship it with arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the scp foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled god just one
of many cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining tau 9
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662 cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the scp foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept out this is impossible the scp site
director wasn't normally a calm or
cheerful man but the researcher had
rarely seen him as angry as he was right
now his face turned a deep beat red as
he scanned the documents on his desk
before he asked how months of valuable
research on this subject had suddenly
gone blank the data was completely gone
the researcher gulped nervously hoping a
demotion wasn't in his future and nodded
how could this be possible this was an
experienced researcher who should have
been taking all the necessary
precautions could the being they were
studying somehow have erased all these
documents himself that's just what the
researcher had been trying to find out
for months with hours and hours spent
trying to learn the extent of its
abilities well where are they the site
director asked i want everything you
have the researcher dropped a printout
of their research on the mysterious
subject's abilities on the director's
desk every relevant line read data lost
the director let out a deep sigh he
wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew well everything he could remember
at least from the beginning the
researcher sat down and began to relay
everything he could about
scp-343 which some of the other
researchers had started to refer to by
the nickname god
scp-343 was first sighted in prague just
an unassuming older man wandering the
streets he seemed completely normal to
everyone who passed him by until he
decided he was tired of staying on the
ground an scp agent stationed in the
area noticed the old man disappear from
the streets as if he was blinking out of
existence only to appear on a rooftop
nearby the local scp teams were
marshalled and they had soon tracked
down what seemed to be a very powerful
specimen but scp-343 didn't seem
concerned he reacted calmly when
detained by the foundation and went with
him willingly he was detained in a
standard holding cell for interrogation
and examination but he seemed completely
at ease with his sudden confinement it
would soon become clear that this
ordinary old man was anything but
doctors back in midlavu was brought in
to consult on the scp's classification
and that's when the first anomalies
began their assessments matched
initially but when it came time to
describe him physically things took a
strange turn older male seemingly
non-descript and with no unusual
physical features caucasian in
appearance dr nadlovu was confused by
what dr beck was describing in his
report this man was clearly black the
two doctors quarreled unable to square
their differing perceptions they decided
to bring in a third impartial view to
settle it their fellow researcher dr
juan she didn't take long before coming
back with her assessment older male
seemingly nondescript and with no
unusual physical features asian in
appearance possibly chinese whatever
scp-343 was he seemed to be perceived by
each staff member as close in appearance
to their own race but that was only the
start of the anomalies surrounding the
old man in the holding cell dr beck
started making regular visits to the
mysterious man and in their first
interview he asked the old man who he
was and how he came by his abilities the
old man had a simple response i created
the universe dr beck stifled the laugh
and decided to indulge the old man's
delusion it was a fascinating claim but
could he prove it without another word
scp-343 got up from his chair laughed
and turned around and walked through the
solid wall in the holding cell and
disappeared dr beck was about to hit the
panic button and marshall the facility's
security to find him when the strange
man reappeared walking through the solid
wall the only thing that was different
he was holding a hamburger which he sat
down and enjoyed the facility quickly
went on lockdown and a full
investigation was done into how
scp-343 breached containment but there
was no evidence of any security breach
no failures and containment and no
evidence of any other cells failing
scp-343 hadn't broken through the
security he had just ignored it as if it
wasn't there at all when questioned
about how he had gone on his hamburger
run he simply repeated his belief that
he was god in between bites of his fast
food treat this would be far from the
only time strange things happened around
scp-343
scp containment cells are as secure as
they need to be but even the least
strict containment isn't known for its
decor which is why dr beck was in for a
surprise the next time he paid visit to
scp-343
the bare-bones cell now looked like a
comfortable home decorated in old
english fashions the scientists assumed
that scp-343 had been making many more
trips out of his cell to get accessories
to feel more at home but that didn't
explain all the changes to the cell no
one could explain how he had installed
the roaring fireplace in the containment
cell and everyone who entered could
swear the cell looked many times bigger
than any other cell in the facility
scp-343 wasn't just breaking containment
he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility the rules of the
scp containment facility didn't seem to
be a concern to scp-343
but there was one thing he didn't seem
to want to do escape after every sudden
exit he would always return to his
personal cell and treat it as his home
when interviewed by staff members he was
polite but vague and everyone seemed to
enjoy talking to him it was decided to
keep him on site not attempt to increase
his security but restrict access and
keep his room guarded at all times to
ensure only researchers with level 3
access and above were allowed to meet
with him but god works in mysterious
ways minimal security site 17 was one of
the least restrictive scp containment
sites hosting anomalies that could be
safely contained and weren't likely to
mount violent escapes but as in every
scp facility security was still taken
seriously and only those with proper
clearance could interact with the
subjects so why did scp-343 seem
impossible to guard while only level 3
clearance and above were allowed in the
guards assigned to protect the entrance
all seemed to fall down on the job
security officer james who was supposed
to be keeping people out of scp-343 cell
had instead let in multiple visitors in
addition to dropping in several times
himself when questioned on why he had
gone against orders and done so he
simply replied that 343 seemed lonely
and was so happy every time he got
company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do the security guard was
reassigned and new ones were brought in
but history repeated itself guards were
given stricter instructions to minimize
exposure but
scp-343's presence always seemed to
influence them anyway his containment
cell was a revolving door with staff
members at the facility entering
regularly for friendly conversations dr
beck decided it was time to take matters
into his own hands he would meet with
scp-343 one-on-one and express how
dangerous these security breaches were
he would try to convince the mysterious
being that he needed to stop influencing
the minds of the guards watching him or
the facility would have to look into new
measures to contain him dr back entered
the containment cell and had a long
conversation with
scp-343 and when he emerged he had a big
smile on his face like he had just
finished a reunion with an old friend he
gave the current guard a friendly clap
on the back and told him not to worry so
much about security after all nothing
bad was gonna happen from letting people
at the facility visit scp-343 right he
wasn't dangerous in any way he also said
that security should bring him anything
he requests so he would feel less need
to leave a cell minimal security site 17
soon became a model scp facility with
morale being the highest of any site
with most giving the credit to the
presence of scp-343
employees generally make daily visits to
his chamber and he seems to have an
encyclopedic knowledge of anything they
want to talk about including things he
should have no way of knowing guards no
longer quit their posts or break
protocol as their only real duty is to
keep track of who meets with scp-343
so they can be interviewed and debriefed
after everyone's conversation is
different but they all report being in a
better mood after leaving than when they
came in no further information is
available on
scp-343's origins the full extent of his
powers or whether he is telling the
truth about being the god who created
the universe the site director rubbed
his temples after hearing the
researcher's explanation so what you're
telling me is that we have an
uncontained highly powerful scp that has
not only been breaking containment
whenever it wants but has managed to
destroy all the files regarding the
research on it the researcher's answer
was yes however the situation at site 17
seemed to be stable and they had come up
with a plan that should help to maximize
the positive effect
scp-343 has on the facility they were
even hypothesizing that staff from other
sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343's presence the site
director wasn't impressed though he
wanted the researcher to go back to the
drawing board and redo the research
after all if all the files were blank
how could they ever learn how to
properly contain it that's what the c
and scp stood for after all containment
the researcher finally had to stand to
the director though and told them that
it wasn't a good idea that they had
already tried everything to contain
scp-343 but that it wasn't that he broke
containment it was as if he didn't even
acknowledge that an attempt had been
made to contain him he was omnipotent
aware of things he shouldn't and able to
do things that broke the laws of physics
without breaking a sweat there was no
evidence that this was god the creator
of the universe as he claimed to be but
there also wasn't any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn't the
researcher's best guess was that this
was a powerful reality bender whose
abilities knew no limits and that the
only reason he was staying in the
facility was because he wanted to and
doing anything to change that might
cause him to change his benevolent ways
the director's side as much as he hated
to admit it his researcher was making
good points he wanted to meet scp-343
personally but did he need to know
anything first well sir the researcher
replied he likes hamburgers but beyond
that he'll take care of the rest he's
right there where we left him in his
home waiting for his next guest the
esteemed doctor thomas morested entered
the cell of the anomaly
he'd been warned and even chastised by
his colleagues
but who in the foundation could tell him
what to do
he was the best at what he did
maybe the greatest in the whole history
of the foundation
as he entered the room
scp-049 bit in welcome cordial as always
so polite in fact that you'd never guess
you were talking to a killer dr morstead
knew the truth of what he was dealing
with
but he also believed he could get
through to 049
calm him exercise the devil from him it
was the meeting of two great minds one
of them human one of them part human
part
something that has never been clear
it was to be a battle of wits and like
so many great battles this one would
turn into a massacre before we get to
that fateful meeting there are some
things you should know about the anomaly
known as scp-049
if you saw him in the street the first
thing you think of is playing because
zero four nine always looked the same a
man dressed in black robes with a plague
doctor's mask but this wasn't a costume
that could be taken off in fact it
wasn't a costume at all
it was him the robes had grown out of
him like an exoskeleton
that horrible mask with the pointed nose
wasn't covering his face it was his face
a kind of shell that had seemingly
sprouted from bone the first reports
came during world war ii in a
picturesque town in the south of france
called montevallo people had begun going
missing children disappeared from their
beds in the middle of the night and
weren't seen again adults went to the
market and never returned local
authorities searched high and low they
scoured nearby woods and dragged the
rivers but nothing was found because
what was happening wasn't criminal there
was no clue they could stumble upon or
eyewitness who would break the case
no this was something else something
that the townsfolk could never
understand word spread and that's when a
search and discovery team was sent from
the foundation it was a cold dark night
in january of 1941 when the team found
what they were looking for they walked
through the open door of a small house
located not too far from the grand
chateau de luis liu to find a masked man
sitting next to an open fire and he
wasn't alone the floor around him looked
like it was moving upon closer
inspection the team saw that the floor
was covered with writhing grasping
bodies it's patience as it called them
bienvenue chamois said the thing welcome
to my home
those so-called patients crawled towards
the team intent it seemed to cause harm
the hostiles now known as scp-049-2s
were deemed dangerous and had to be
eliminated a sight it seemed that didn't
bother 0-4-9 in the slightest it just
sat there occasionally looking up from
writing notes in a leather-bound book as
his patients were gunned down once the
carnage ended it simply closed its book
stood up and allowed itself to be
escorted away and that's the story of
how 049 ended up at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 02 site 19. the few
that came into contact with 049 remarked
that it was a pleasure for them with its
impeccable manners vast knowledge of
medicine and human anatomy sharp tongue
and stinging weight they almost became
spellbound listening to it caught in the
throes of its charms until with the
simple touch of its hand it would drain
the life from them that's why
scp-049 was classified as a euclid
that's why armed guards were always
stationed outside itself it's why
doctors took great precautions when in
its presence and it's why dr morristead
should have known better remember when
049 was discovered in france it
willingly went with the team like it was
happy it had been found as if it had
planned its own capture when it arrived
at the facility it didn't act like it
was contained against its well it was
like it was returning home
initial findings as to the biology of
049 were that it didn't require any
sustenance at all not even water it
seemed content to be left alone with its
notebooks it did not object when it was
asked if it could share some of its
notes and gladly handed over its
journals but upon examination it was
discovered that they were written in the
language that no linguist or
cryptologist has so far been able to
translate it's apparent that 049 derives
much satisfaction from seeing so-called
experts struggle over its text unable to
read those notes a long line of doctors
visited 049 in itself each fascinated by
what they beheld it was learned that it
has traveled the globe it speaks many
languages but prefers to speak what it
calls le long de la mor french it asks
for only one thing
warm-blooded animals the facility agreed
to supply 049 with various kinds
including rabbits cattle and even an ape
on one occasion just like with humans it
could kill the animals with a mere touch
of its hand sucking the life right out
of them but that wasn't even the most
incredible part soon those animals would
rise again as if reanimated by 049 they
would become for all intents and
purposes
the living dead
and they were hostile after several
unfortunate incidents they were taken
from the cell the moment they arose and
disposed of in the incinerator
this was not to the liking of 049 who
would claim it had cured the animals for
it the world was sick it saw plague and
pestilence everywhere and the meaning of
its existence was to rid the world of
disease
humans it said contained a virus and had
to be cleansed in the first days after
arriving at the facility 049 didn't seem
to pose a threat to humans it was quite
friendly in fact it seemed aware of the
fear it caused in staff and would often
go out of its way to make them feel
comfortable and safe this was a ruse of
course or a canard as 049 like to say it
had no intention to help humans
no
it had come for humans it wasn't trapped
it had set a trap one of the first
people to truly upset 049 was dr raymond
hamm a well-respected physician that had
twice been a contender for the nobel
prize for his more mainstream work what
had confused dr ham the most was not
zero four nine's closed-like exoskeleton
or even his ability to reanimate the
dead but the bag that it used zero four
nine was somehow able to pull a
seemingly endless supply of surgical
tools from that bag sometimes it would
even pull out objects that were somehow
larger than the bag itself it was as if
the bag connected to somewhere else and
that's what dr ham wanted to talk about
on that fateful day with 049 on one side
of the cell and dr ham on the other he
asked how is it that you can produce a
great quantity of tools from that bag
i've observed you and it seems to me
that you are doing the impossible dear
doctor
replied049 the scourge the great dying
cannot be fought with a handful of toys
my bag is merely the product of my
imagination it gives me what i require
you dear sir it seems are limited by
your imagination it stopped for a second
or two and stared at dr ham i detect you
are unwell it said in a voice not as
amiable as before it's just a cold said
the doctor ah
just the cold if you had seen what i
have seen you would not utter such
insulting words dr ham pulled out some
papers from a briefcase and approached
049 holding them close enough so it
could read them you see said dr ham
pointing to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not diseased
they were perfectly healthy before they
died and your so-called cure it turned
them into something quite terrible we
found that if they were left alone they
began to eat each other and then
themselves 049 did not respond and after
a brief pause said only a good day to
your doctor please close the door on
your way out you should get some rest
ham refused to go and instead turn the
conversation to this real interest
the bag demanding that 049 let him see
inside of it very well doctor 049 said
in private 049 began to pull a series of
long metal poles out of its bag followed
by a rolled up curtain that it hung
between them creating a kind of medical
tent around dr ham it seemed to stare
for just a moment into the observation
camera outside of itself before whipping
the curtain shut dr ham was discovered
three hours later crawling around the
floor of zero four nine's cell now
another mindless undead
when he was retrieved by security 049
didn't even look up from his notebook dr
ham didn't get the incinerator treatment
but he did receive a fatal dose of drugs
a mercy a removal team was sent to 049
cell but it had said there was no need
for special extraction techniques it
would go willingly wherever they wanted
to go it was not it said an enemy of the
people the hippocratic oath forbids me
to hurt a human being it said while
walking to the interrogation center my
only desire is to offer you my services
and expertise
the floors and walls of the
interrogation center room were painted a
bright white even the table was white
which contrasted with 049 a mass of
black sitting in the middle of the room
during the interrogation it refused to
admit or even accept that it had killed
dr ham i cured him i removed the
pestilence from his body it said it was
later asked if it regretted its actions
to which it replied well good sir one
always regrets the loss of a colleague
for any reason but i stand by my actions
the pestilence must be abated before it
is too late every two weeks from that
point zero four nine was given animals
the scientists at the facility observed
it time and again touching the animals
killing them before producing a saw or
scalpel and opening them up organs would
be carefully removed with perfect
precision it was astounding to even
train surgeons just how talented 049 was
i require a close relative of yours said
049 one day to a young doctor who
expressed shock that it was as for one
of the doctors family members i mean a
great eight said zero four nine
not your dear aunt there were several
instances of zero four nine displaying a
crude sense of humor staff would almost
forget that the thing that they were
talking to wasn't human almost and it
was dr thomas morestad that had supplied
the great apes orangutans in fact that
had been rescued from the rainforests of
borneo only to be taken to zero four
nine south then one day something
changed zero four nine told dr morstead
that its work was done that it
accomplished what it had wanted to do
and could someone remove the cured
animal from itself i think you'd find
that it's quite the work of art a
triumph 049 said through the intercom
when the removal team entered the cell
they found the orangutan or what was
left of it it was lying in the corner of
the cell the top of its skull had been
removed leaving its brain exposed on its
face was the expression of relaxation
and from its mouth it issued very soft
squeaks like that of an infant 049 said
tell dr morristed that its rage
mechanism no longer exists i've removed
the amygdala and made some changes to
the hypothalamus and limbic system it is
cured and quite harmless the next day dr
morstead announced that he wanted to
visit 049 cell himself after which he
heard a course of disapproval from his
colleagues
all telling him that 049 was now too
dangerous dr ham was sick replied more
stead and 049 has assured us that he
would never take another human life he's
never lied to us and i'm going to take
him at his word
it appeared that 049 had created the
perfect specimen so what was next
dr morristead had to know
everyone is sick 049 told dr morristed
after the two had talked for a couple of
minutes the great pandemic has started
fear not doctor i have a cure no longer
will you humans spread your disease i'm
afraid you are wrong replied the doctor
this pandemic you speak of does not
exist we can happily live with our
pathogens we have done so for millennia
dr morstead became angry that he
couldn't get through to zero four nine
i'm afraid you are suffering from
paranoia it is you who need to be cured
you have no idea said 049 standing up
what are you doing shouted morristead
you promised you wouldn't hurt a human
again i'm not hurting you i'm healing
you 049 said and leapt across the room
in a flash placing a hand on the
doctor's head more stead slumped to the
ground they were being watched in the
observation room and this had gone too
far he had to be moved to the
containment cells permanently mobile
task force epsilon 11 was right on the
scene and burst through the door
now imagine nation 049 said to himself
those humans have no imagination at all
he began walking towards the task force
who opened fire on the anomaly but the
bullets bounced off its black code and
mask
scp-049 calmly touched each of the
members of the task force one by one
draining the life from them the last one
standing stopped firing and attempted to
run but again zero four nine left across
the room black cape billowing out behind
him and gently touched the man causing
him to drop to the floor zero four nine
stepped over the bodies of the fallen
team and walked out of the containment
cell the full details of what happened
next are available only to the o5
council what are sometimes called the
overseers the redacted report that is
available reads standard secure humanoid
containment cell research sector 02 site
19 subject
scp-049 date of breach redacted euclid
class scp-049 breach cell and
subsequently gained access to adjoining
rooms and nearby buildings breach lasted
approximately three days and five hours
total casualties redacted with redacted
number of survivors requiring
incineration therapy course of action
department of science alchemy division
suggested injecting anti-transmogrify
disinfected into class-d former
prisoners who were transported to site
and allowed them to come into contact
with scp-049
scp failed to reanimate injected
prisoners and cure them
scp-049 acknowledged this failure and
surrendered to mobile task force alpha-1
scp-049 then requested to be contained
present containment under responsibility
of redacted rejected present location of
scp-049 redacted end of report we were a
team
despite our differences
in spite of the terrible things they'd
done
we were still a team
that's not how the higher up saw it
though
no
the guys upstairs with their perfectly
pressed shirts
for them we were judged by our level of
expendability and they knew that our
next mission was a death sentence
one by one that thing
took out my team
my
friends snapping their necks so quickly
and with such ease that no sooner did i
hear the scream
they were dead
we had been used
i'd been used
delivered as prey to the predator
a plot that was sanctioned by the bosses
and approved with a blood red stamp
why did they do it
i'm still trying to figure that out
maybe that's something you can tell me
after you hear how these so-called
scientific men left us in the cell
and in the hands of scp-173
for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times
the best because i'd quickly risen
through the ranks of the facility
the worst because well
i'll get to that
i was never the best student i finished
high school by the skin of my teeth and
my job prospects looked bleak
but i was lucky i guess
or at least i thought so at the time
you see i have an uncle siegfried who
did some work for the government
i never actually knew what he did just
that it was secretive work
i used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
i was when he found out i needed a job
and he offered to help me out
i couldn't believe it
i always thought he hated me
i'd overheard him telling my parents
that i was a no-good deadbeat but now
he'd have a change of heart and was
willing to take me under his wing
but what i get to do
undercover intelligence gathering
international assassinations
just you wait he said
and that's how i found myself walking
into a sprawling futuristic looking
facility where they handed me a level
one security clearance card with big
bold letters that read
janitor but i was happy
just the words security clearance made
me feel important and it beat flipping
burgers
i pushed mops turned off lights fired up
generators clocked in and clocked out
but all that time they must have been
watching me
grooming me
waiting for the day they could throw me
to the wolves
i should have known
i've always been an expendable kind of
guy
after a few years i was called to an
office and there was a man in a plaid
shirt and kind of a tweed jacket that
professors wear
he asked me
do you have any idea about what we
actually do here
and to be honest
i didn't i knew that there were many
parts of the facility i couldn't enter
i imagine that down a maze of corridors
were weapons being built or prisoners
being interrogated but i had no idea
about the anomalies how could i before i
was told anything i had to sign a bunch
of forms there were so many i thought
i'd get to find out who really killed
jfk
and while they didn't come out and say
it what i inferred was that if i ever
talk about what happens at the facility
to someone outside the facility well
let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they'd spell out on a piece of
paper but it involves padded cells and
rusty tools
i wasn't scared though
i was part of something big something
secret
and i loved it so i signed my life away
with no hesitation
soon after i was introduced to my first
anomaly the safe class of course
they took me to an observation room from
that room i could see into another room
with a sign on the wall that read
scp-067 i just stood there waiting for
something to happen when in walked
another guy in a white lab coat welcome
to your first anomaly he said is it okay
if i hook you up to this heart monitor
we want to gauge your reaction to what
you see
all i can see i told them is an empty
room with a table and what looks like a
pen on top of some papers
correct he said half smiling as if i was
some kind of idiot
that's scp-06
i thought about telling him that if i
needed years of training before i could
see a pen that i probably should have
taken that fast food job could have been
a shift manager by now
then they brought a young chimpanzee
into the room small enough to be
harmless one of the guys forced a pen
into the scared ship's hand and
something strange happened it started
scribbling
nonsense at first but suddenly it was
sketching and drawing faster and faster
i could catch glimpses of words and
images by the time they dragged it out
it was flailing around like it was
possessed that pen has power said the
man in the lab coat a power whose source
or origin we don't fully understand
that's why we're here
that's why you are here one of the guys
in the other room held the chimps
drawing up to the window it was a
perfect sketch of the tower of london
intricate and brilliant
above the sketch was the title tower of
london tudor period circa 1541 the year
margaret pole the countess of salisbury
lost her head on the chopping block
underneath that the chimp had written
pity she was no traitor
take it from me i was there they didn't
need to look at the heart rate monitor
to see that i was shocked
that was far from the only anomaly i'd
come into contact with and i must have
been doing something right because in
time i went from level 1 to 2 to level 3
security clearance and that's when they
made me a containment specialist i won't
bore you with all the details but as you
can guess i dealt with the containment
of anomalies a lot of my time was spent
looking through small windows and cell
doors making sure that whatever was
inside was still inside and still in one
piece
other times i worked with field agents
when anomalies were brought in a
transition period that the arrested
freaks didn't much like
there was one certain anomaly though
that i was tasked to oversee on many
occasions i like to think of it as my
pet
but in hindsight
i was it's pet
this was
scp-173 something that was in what we
call the euclid class classification
meaning that we don't fully understand
it but know it is very dangerous
we know it's intelligent we know it's
unpredictable
and we know it will kill and for that
reason there's people tasked with
containing it and keeping an eye on it
at all times
at first glance you wouldn't guess just
how dangerous 173 is you wouldn't think
it's incredibly intelligent in fact
you'd think the opposite that's because
it's more or less a walking slab of
concrete and rebar with stunted limbs
and traces of spray paint that give the
impression of a dopey face
we have to enter itself twice a week for
cleaning duties it leaves a disgusting
foul-smelling liquid on the floor a
reddish-brown substance that i can only
describe as a mix of blood and waste
products
where that stuff comes from has remained
a mystery since we first contained it in
1993.
going into the cell was always the
three-man job because and this is maybe
the weirdest part about 173 it can't
move if human eyes are watching it
that's why you need at least two people
watching it at all times if you're in
the room watching 173 by yourself and
blinked you'd be dead before your eyes
opened
we don't know how it moves that fast but
in that fraction of a second your neck
is snapped so hard it's almost like
being decapitated i've seen the videos
to prove it
all it took was a sneeze he wasn't even
finished getting the rest of the achoo
out when there was a flash and his
partner was left lying on the ground
his head twisted around the wrong
direction so you can understand why we
now require three men for any time we
must enter 173 cell
then a few months ago i was told that a
long process would begin to train and
re-educate some future class d's
class d's are mostly prisoners with
lifelong sentences or those we've taken
from death row and given a new lease on
life we were apparently understaffed so
why not employ these men whose lives had
pretty much ended anyway that was the
rationale or at least that's what they
told me i was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173's mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
specialists could focus on more
important tasks
they hadn't been through the training i
had seen what i had seen
but after showing them the video of 173
nearly taking off a man's head they were
more than willing to follow the rules
they understood not to blink or turn
away or sneeze
and that any lapse in focus could lead
to a violent death so i started to show
them the ropes how we move as a team
into the cell and always keep the others
informed on what we're doing
173 was always sitting in the corner of
a cell no expression on that crude face
but when we walked in itself i got the
feeling it knew something had changed
i felt almost as if it was communicating
with me but i couldn't tell what it was
trying to say
and then
it happened
it was a tuesday afternoon three days
from the last time we'd cleaned
as usual 173 had covered the floor with
that horrible liquid
we headed in to clean my new team alert
us always and some of them cleaned while
others kept their eyes focused on the
thing in the corner things were going
smoothly when we heard a noise i knew
very well
it was the sound of the cell door
locking
someone must have screwed up
hey guys we're locked in here i shot it
through the intercom
nothing
guys the damn door is locked
nothing
i lost it a bit open the door will you
nothing
my team looked at me
the ones not on eye contact duty that is
as if i should know what to do
hoping that this had happened before and
that there was some kind of standard
plan to deal with it
there wasn't
we were always observed when in the room
and i knew that a technician couldn't
accidentally lock the door
it was impossible there were protocols
someone had done this on purpose
the four of us sat in the corner of the
room as far from 173 as possible our
eyes locked on it it didn't move an inch
as usual
just stood staring at the wall as it
always did
we stayed awake through the night
talking a little holding on to the slim
hope that something had gone wrong
but as night turned to day again we all
began to lose hope
we weren't sent here to clean
we were a test
totally expendable
lab rats but i wouldn't go down without
a fight we couldn't just stay up forever
that was a death sentence i suggested
that two of us stand one sit and rest
and one get some sleep
we'd take shifts a couple hours on a
couple hours off
maybe we could show that we wouldn't
give up they'd have time to realize what
they were doing was insane call off the
test and come free us
we made it through a couple of shifts
like this and it seemed like we'd
actually be able to make it another day
or two when everything went wrong
it was my turn to sit and rest when i
heard the worst possible noise
snoring
the con next to me was sleeping quietly
so it must be one of the standers i
glanced over for just a split second and
saw both of them
leaning against the cell wall dozing at
the same time i saw the flash crack snap
pop
one after another their necks were
snapped i'm not sure how it happened but
i was standing again staring at 173 who
was now in the corner dead bodies with
their heads twisted around piled up in
front of it i couldn't take it anymore i
couldn't stare at this thing forever i
felt myself giving up i lowered my head
to the ground and then finally broke my
gaze
ready to die
and then
nothing happened i slowly raised my head
back up and there it was it's hideous
face inches away from mine it was then
that i understood what we'd been
containing
what we'd underestimated
i felt it again like it was telling me
something
was telling me to close my eyes
to sleep
so i did but as my eyes closed i didn't
see darkness
i saw 173
or something like it
but not in the cell
i saw it outside
in the world
standing over children sleeping in their
beds
watching
i saw them hiding in the shadows
staring out at
passersby then i realized they weren't
watching
waiting to pounce
no
they were hiding
my eyes popped open as the door opened
and inrushed six security personnel
they took me outside jabbed my leg with
a syringe injecting me with something as
the world
faded
away
incident report time and date redacted
following the experimental forced
interaction with euclid-class anomaly
scp-173
subject has ceased responding to
external stimuli and appears to have
taken on the traits and behaviors of the
anomaly subject now spends entire days
sitting in corner of cell staring at the
wall
staff are advised to proceed with
caution when dealing with subject as the
only behavior they engage in is an
attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell no treatments have shown any
effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever the scp foundation is no
stranger to pure evil whether it's a
reptile that wants to end all life a
sadistic old man with his own tortured
dimension or the personification of
death itself lurking beyond a limestone
cavern but what if there was something
even worse out there the embodiment of
chaos and cruelty existing across
multiple realities and dimensions and
what if it was coming for us
this is the scarlet king believed by
many to be the ultimate evil behind much
of the trouble the foundation has faced
and some even speculate that fighting
him was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the scarlet king he's known
by many names almost always including
some allusion to the color red and then
a reference to royalty or power
the red shah the crimson khan pte 616
mendez ex machina the lahar raja and of
course scp-001
to name a few and like many of the
foundation's mysterious enemies stories
about his true nature and origins abound
and are often contradictory according to
the official
scp-001 files of tufto's proposal
symbology of the scarlet king has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the king often depicted the
same way as a huge red demonic figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating royalty he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities that the
scp foundation is familiar with are
believed to be somehow connected to the
scarlet king including
scp-2317 a wooden door leading to the
realm of a being known as the devourer
who is expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the scarlet king strangely
the foundation's official file on the
scarlet king once designated his
containment class as ketter but that has
since been downgraded to safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the scarlet king still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
o5 council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the scarlet king we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it dr robert
montauk if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the scarlet
king's most recent attempts to enter our
reality scp-231
this scp often referred to as the brides
of the scarlet king was formed of seven
women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent in
a long line of the king's devoted cults
known as the children of the scarlet
king each of these seven unfortunate
women were impregnated with anomalous
horrors such as the infamous scp-682
and every time one of these horrors were
birthed the catastrophe occurred and the
mother died at the time dr montauk was a
prominent researcher studying this
anomaly and as six catastrophes had
already occurred pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final
birth but as he was working on the issue
dr montauk was struck with a personal
tragedy the mysterious disappearance of
his 14 year old brother jacob in his
fear and anger montauk believed that
this must have something to do with the
scarlet king and his disciples wanting
revenge montauk proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
montauk to be performed on the final
bride at regular intervals however this
wasn't the end of dr montauk's fraught
relationship with the scarlet king it
was just the beginning to give you some
perspective on just how dangerous the
scarlet king is the scp foundation and
the global occult coalition decided to
put aside their differences and form a
joint effort to stamp out the children
of the scarlet king they were successful
in this mission and even managed to
capture the children's leader a
mysterious man named depeche spivak dr
montauk who became the lead researcher
on 231 and 2317 was naturally the first
choice for interviewing depeche about
the true nature of the children and of
the scarlet king
dr montauk could never be the impartial
interviewer that the scp foundation
wanted though
the suspicion that the scarlet king or
the children had something to do with
the loss of his younger brother
still lingered just beneath the surface
like a lot of cult leaders depeche was
extremely cryptic in his answers to dr
montauk's questioning he'd already heard
of the doctor from the reputation of the
horrifying montauk procedure and was
surprised to see him so calm and
courteous in person a few key facts
about the king and his cult were
revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals depeche also revealed that the
scarlet king is bound by three laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling dr montauk confused and
frustrated by depeche's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old memoir from a
former member of the children of the
scarlet king jack hirsch who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the scarlet king and his
followers and a group of time-traveling
turkmen warriors from
scp-3838 hearst saw both sides of the
battle from the perspective of the
children of the scarlet king their lord
ruled over them from an immense fortress
embedded in a volcano from the
perspective of the turkmen the children
were starved and beaten peasants
commanded by the king's voice in the
roaring howl of the wind montauk also
found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various scarlet
king aligned cults interestingly some of
them incorporated the use of carved scp
foundation symbols what could this mean
montauk returned again to depesh who
finally gave him the truth about the law
of blood this is the law of the scarlet
king it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like the serfs in the middle ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the nobles to the children of the
scarlet king this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the modern age defined by empty
safety and false comfort buildings easy
to access food healthcare knowledge
technology this is everything that the
scarlet king despises but the mystery
only deepened as montauk found files
from a former foundation operative by
the name of agent de beauvoir montauk
learned that the scarlet king didn't
seem to appear
until after the foundation was created
and in fact it seemed that the greater
interest the foundation took in the
scarlet king the more powerful he became
how could this be
things were also getting stranger on a
personal level for dr montauk depeche
repeatedly pressed him about his
brother's disappearance and the montauk
procedure during the interviews little
by little it was beginning to take its
toll the questions still plagued him
what was the law of howling who or what
really is the scarlet king how did he
come to be montauk's search was causing
him to act more like the children of the
scarlet king ranting about the horrors
of the modern world how all of us are
living a lie how the only honest way to
live is suffering under the dominion of
the scarlet king this philosophy is
summed up in the words of one cultist
named arya danae cartwright who said we
must learn what it is to die to be
enslaved truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
and darkness the tempest tossed refuge
of a race of fools we must kill
modernity postmodernity with all its
analysis and sneering observation there
is only one rule the rule of chaos for
humanity for life for the scarlet king
basically any time humanity tries to
exert control over the world the scarlet
king gets stronger every time they try
to understand or organize or categorize
their world the scarlet king gets
stronger as colonial and imperial powers
conquered and invaded lands like india
africa and south america and subjugated
their beliefs under western ideas the
scarlet king grew stronger montauk was
beginning to truly understand the power
of his enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
montauk slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the scarlet king's greatest enemy the
scp foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
montauk's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depeche spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the scarlet king foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depeche demanded a final interview
with montauk with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depeche congratulated
montauk for finally understanding what
he was dealing with the scarlet king
dipesh told him is an idea a concept he
is a being given power through the
conflict between the old and the new
this is the law of the howling the
scarlet king's endless rage at the
direction the world and humanity has
taken the king according to depeche
hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than petty arrogance the
reason montauk's procedure on the final
bride of the scarlet king was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in the
scarlet kings realm that would be all
there is
unless our world and especially the
foundation changed its course the
scarlet king's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable montauk his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the scarlet king
take his brother jacob when dipesh told
him the answer no and in response
montauk shot him dead finally bringing
an end to the children of the scarlet
king in light of his new revelations
montauk begged the o5 council to change
their ways in order to avoid letting the
scarlet king break into our reality they
refused saying montauk's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the scarlet
king they would have to take some steps
and so the o5 council of the scp
foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the scarlet king from
ketter to safe and made its description
on the official foundation files
deliberately vague the o5 council thinks
this will be enough to stop the scarlet
king's power from continuing to grow but
montauk knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation was going on as
normal montauk grew to despise them he
knew the scarlet king was coming he knew
that he couldn't be stopped and that our
whole reality was little more than
sitting ducks dr robert montauk is no
longer a researcher for the scp
foundation no dr robert montauk chose a
different path he's now a child of the
scarlet king a devotee of madness hate
and chaos you can't beat the scarlet
king after all and as the old adage goes
if you can't beat them
join them when an anomaly is first
detected by an scp foundation field
agent it's up to the foundation's mobile
task forces to tag and bag the
impossible entities before they can do
any more harm sometimes these retrievals
are uneventful other times
not so much
especially when they're dealing with
brutal forces of nature like scp-096
also known as the shy guy a creature
that from the very first interaction
with the foundation
had a reputation for being dangerous and
needed to be feared
a series of vague sightings and
mysterious disappearances up in the
frosty mountains of the yukon first
sparked the foundation's interest when
they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams zulu 9a and zulu 9b were
dispatched to secure and contain the
entity
zulu9a took the lead in a heavy-duty
chopper equipped with 50 caliber gau-19
heavy machine guns and carrying an at4
anti-tank launcher they were prepared
for anything or so they thought as they
established a visual on
scp-096 while two clicks away from the
target they couldn't get a clear line of
sight on the creature but it appeared to
be stationary docile and was making no
attempt to flay a piece of cake right
little did they know that
scp-096 was just looking away from them
if it was facing towards them it'd be a
whole different horror story as zulu9a
were about to find out the team landed
their helicopter next to the creature
and were shocked to see that it was
completely naked in spite of the
sub-zero temperatures all around them
the creature was unnaturally thin as
though it had been starved for weeks
with bone white skin and unnaturally
long lips the team guessed that the
creature's arms must have been at least
1.5 meters long but its docile nature
and insubstantial body mass gave the
impression that it wouldn't prove too
difficult to contain that is
until they saw its face
zulu9a's captain was the lone survivor
of the incident as he was lucky enough
to be looking away when the creature
turned towards his team the rest of the
squad ended up staring eye to eye with
scp-096
and from that moment on wasn't docile
anymore the creature began to whimper
then cry then sob uncontrollably in a
way that sounded eerily human this
sudden change in temperament startled
the rest of zulu 9a and they opened fire
on the creature under the hail of
gunfire scp-019 entered a murderous
frenzy and began tearing into the
hapless squad of soldiers while its
flesh and organs did seem to take damage
as a result of the barrage of 50 caliber
rounds from the helicopter mounted
machine guns
its skeletal structure remained intact
and it continued its onslaught tearing
the team limb from limb even after they
blown practically all the flesh from the
creature
the at4 anti-tank launcher proved
equally ineffective at stopping scp-096
while it was in attack mode
and it was only after slaughtering the
entire team that it returned to its
docile state nobody knows exactly what
the creature did to zulu 9a after the
gunfire started but no trace of the team
was left behind zulu 9b touched down
soon after and with a grave warning from
the captain not to look at the
creature's face they were finally able
to subdue it a bag was placed over
scp-096's face which seemed to soothe it
enough to move it to a nearby foundation
facility little did they know they just
obtained one of the deadliest scps of
all time and while it may have been
under lock and key for now it seemed
inevitable that it would get out and
cause more violence and chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp-096 were put under the command
of dr dan a senior researcher at the
site it was his job to find out exactly
what this being was capable of the more
he tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its attack mode
just as it had during the initial
retrieval mission
scp-096 went berserk when any of the
attending personnel saw its face in this
stage it would enter a period of
considerable and unstoppable distress
for one to two minutes covering its face
and wailing loudly when the period of
distress ended the creature would
mercilessly slaughter every d-class that
had seen its face and just like with
zulu9a no trace of their bodies would be
left behind
dr den was horrified and intrigued by
this phenomenon the creature killed
anyone that saw its face directly but
could the same be said for indirect
depictions of the creature's face
such as images and videos
dr dan was desperate to find out more
d-class personnel were brought in to
test this to frightening results dr dan
found that the creature did indeed still
enter attack mode when people saw
pictures and videos of
scp-096's face the creature seemed to
have an innate sense of when people were
viewing these representations even when
it should have had no conceivable way of
knowing it didn't matter how far away or
how many barriers were in place between
the viewer and the creature the attack
mode would still activate and once it
did it seemed as though nothing could
stop the creature from hunting down the
one who saw its face with all this new
data special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key its cell was a five
meter by five meter by five meter
airtight steel cube
fitted with advanced pressure sensors
and laser detectors to ensure that
scp-096 remained in itself without
risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature's face all cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden
and weekly checks for any cracks or
holes in the containment cell were
mandatory
of course none of this would stop the
creature if anyone somehow saw its face
in order to solve that little problem dr
dan would need to continue his research
to find a method of subverting the
creature's deadly glance they needed to
know exactly what they were dealing with
but how could they when even a glance at
a photo or video of the being meant
certain death
a potential solution was proposed
creating an artistic representation of
the creature's face something that
hadn't yet been attempted but how would
they achieve such a fee simple they'd
procure a d-class prisoner with some
artistic talent
and they found one who had been a tattoo
artist before becoming a foundation
guinea pig
dr dan formulated an ingenious plan for
keeping this d-class alive for long
enough to accurately draw an image of
scp-096's face
you would be placed in a bathysphere
diving bell several kilometers
underwater and tens of kilometers away
from the containment cell where the scp
was being held the d-class was made to
look at a photograph of the creature's
face and then replicate that image in a
pencil sketch
dr dan first confirmed that the
creature's attack mode is only activated
by the creature's face by having the
d-class look at a series of photos of
the scp's body parts one by one finally
finishing with its face the d-class
began drawing and even remarked on how
creepy the scp's facial features were
despite not knowing the deadly context
meanwhile back in its containment cell
scp-096
sent someone viewing its face and
entered its inconsolable crying state
followed by its attack mode it broke out
of containment easily and began making a
b line for the d-class traversing the
miles between it and its prey the
d-class didn't know it as he locked the
finished drawing into a separate
autonomous submersible but he was
already dead
as the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface
scp-096 dived into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the bathysphere was breached
and the d-class was torn to shreds
scp-096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team foxtrot 303a
and further testing on the drawings
showed that artistic representations of
scp-096's face were in fact harmless
from this experience we now know that
the creature has a gaunt face with
totally white eyes possibly indicating
blindness and a grossly extended jaw
nevertheless dr dan was adamant that
scp-096 was too dangerous to be left
alive and requested permission from the
upper echelons of the foundation to
terminate the creature by any means
necessary however the doctor's request
would fall on deaf ears
until
it all started with a seemingly innocent
image
while it's now been redacted for your
safety the black speck inside the yellow
circle was once a minuscule image of
scp-096
taken unknowingly in the 1990s by a
semi-professional mountaineer one day
they were looking at old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny speck
without even noticing that he had seen
anything but scp-096 noticed and began
entering its attack mode it tore through
its steel containment unit like tissue
paper causing the release of a nerve
agent that killed a number of attending
foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force tau one in hot
pursuit dr olixi who is helping to
manage the site where the scp was
contained was in dismay over the
situation dr dan was out of the country
at the time trying to discover more
about the creature's origins however he
did leave the mobile task force with a
new secret weapon against the rampaging
shy guy
project scramble scramble were
state-of-the-art goggles featuring a new
technology created by dr dan which using
artistic renditions of 096's facial
features could detect and scramble the
features of scp-096 into an
unrecognizable form preventing the
normally deadly effect of gazing upon
its face
in theory this would allow mtf tau1 to
engage safely with 096 once its prey had
been eliminated and bring it back into
containment but disaster struck on two
fronts first the prey in question was
located in a population center creating
the potential for a huge loss of life
and the second bigger problem was that
the scramble technology didn't work as
stray pixels of the creature's face
would reach the eyes of the task force
before the internal microprocessor had
time to scramble them the mission turned
into a death sentence as scp-096
slaughtered almost the entire task force
as well as a number of civilians in town
including an infant and its entire
family it was a monumental disaster made
even worse by a final revelation dr dan
and dr alexey had themselves facilitated
the entire containment breach and
allowed the resulting massacre to happen
with dr dan hoping it would be enough
motivation for foundation command to
green light his research into destroying
the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the bloodshed his plan worked and
the scp foundation saw it his way
approving his request to neutralize
scp-096
however success comes at a cost for dr
dan once he figures out a way to finally
kill the creature though done in his
line of duty he himself will be
terminated by the foundation for his
crimes against humanity
but considering how much damage scp-096
is capable of causing if it ever got to
a major population center or even worse
was ever caught on camera and broadcast
to a worldwide audience the doctor
himself would likely deem his own death
a justifiable cost
to this day the foundation is
researching ways to kill the creature
and they're still looking for their
silver bullet
and the pressure is on they hadn't known
about the seemingly innocent picture
that sparked the last containment breach
the one taken decades ago in which the
shy guy had only occupied four tiny
pixels four tiny pixels that resulted in
multiple innocent lives lost
so be careful where you look because who
knows how many other photos of the
creature are lurking out there photos
with an innocent dot in the background
your eyes glance over it not even
noticing the little blip
until you hear a distant wailing that
seems to be getting closer and closer
and closer
and then
it's already too late
the scp foundation does their best to
live up to their famous namesake they
secure and contain anomalies and
monsters from all around the world or
sometimes even offworld and protect the
public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose
however despite their efforts to
maintain security and keep their
subjects under lock and key there are
sometimes creatures so clever so devious
and so determined to escape their
captivity and wreak havoc on the world
that even the scp foundation struggles
to keep them from getting free
one example is scp-035
or the possessive mask
scp-035 is one of the most dangerous
test subjects in scp foundation custody
and its mere presence at the foundation
has resulted in untold damage
death and destruction it seems innocent
enough to the untrained eye the mask
which resembles a classic white
porcelain comedy mask though it
occasionally changes its expression to
tragedy has been in existence since at
least the 1800s
in the late 19th century the foundation
discovered the mask in a sealed crypt
beneath an abandoned home in venice it
is unknown how it got there or how the
foundation knew to look for it if there
was ever an explanation for its
discovery that has long since been
removed or redacted from the
foundation's archives you're probably
wondering how can a simple mask leave
multiple season foundation employees
dead well like everything at the scp
foundation this mask is not what it
seems there is a reason its
classification is ketter a designation
that refers to an entity that's
excessively difficult to contain and it
couples this difficulty with a
pronounced hostility towards human life
and the ability to cause widespread
destruction in the event of a
containment breach
these are the qualities that the poor
unfortunate souls assigned to guard
scp-035 would come to understand
all too well
the possessive mask is a parasitic
entity constantly seeking out a host
willing to put it on any human being in
the mask's proximity experiences a
sudden unexplainable urge to put it on
and once they do there's no going back
scp foundation research has determined
that once a host has put on the mask
their brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern this one coming from
the mask rendering the host effectively
brain dead once the host's brain
function has been eliminated the mask
takes over piloting their body and even
speaking through them however the mask
can only occupy a hose for a small
amount of time before the body begins to
decay and decompose eventually rotting
away completely leaving nothing but
desiccated flesh and bones where there
once was a person
scp-035 is capable of possessing any
humanoid being whether that's an actual
human being or a lifeless humanoid shape
despite all their research the scp
foundation unknowingly gave the mask all
the tools and resources it needed to
break containment and leave a trail of
bodies in its wake for a time the mask
was given host privileges meaning that
it was purposely allowed to occupy a
host in order to speak with the
scientists studying it in order to avoid
murky ethical issues the host was
usually something inanimate like a
mannequin or a statue these conditions
however unsettling allowed the
researchers to carry out interviews with
the consciousness housed inside the mask
in the hope of beginning to understand
it and its motivations however
scp-035 lost all access to its host
privileges after it almost pulled off an
unprecedented
shocking and nearly catastrophic escape
attempt
in its early days at the facility when
it was still allowed host privileges it
was contained in a triple locked room
and monitored by several research
personnel
these were experienced researchers who
had been with the foundation for a
minimum of five years each an unusually
long tenure in such a dangerous and
mentally corrosive line of work these
research staff members were thought to
be the most capable of handling
interactions with the mask and be able
to resist its attempts at manipulation
unfortunately these assumptions were
naive and seriously underestimated the
mask's power research on the mask
indicates that the mask is incredibly
intelligent and a skilled manipulator it
has a photographic memory intelligence
that would rank it in the 99th
percentile of humans and the ability to
incite dramatic changes in the behavior
and people that it talks to
one particularly in famous interview
between the entity and an unnamed doctor
at the foundation suggested that the
mask may even possess telepathic
abilities the mask was able to give
details about the doctor's life that no
one else was privy to including
knowledge of an affair that his wife was
having following the interview the
doctor suffered a psychotic break and
committed suicide just 24 hours later
the mask is able to use its superior
intelligence charismatic personality and
mind reading abilities to get inside the
heads of those it speaks with it will
pull out any and all psychological stops
to get what it wants leaving broken
minds and spirits in its wake
it was really only a matter of time
before it used this skill set to its
advantage and attempted to escape its
confinement
the day of the escape attempt was like
any other the research staff a team of
three intelligent experienced men
checked into the facility measured the
conditions of the mask's containment
unit and began the process of
interviewing the mask like normal its
motions were slow and looked to require
great effort as its current host was
beginning to degrade beyond use
the mask was attached to the blank face
of a mannequin and corrosive black
liquid could be seen oozing from its eye
and mouth holes this liquid is excreted
by the mask at a near constant rate
and it's thought to be at least
partially responsible for the
accelerated decay of the host bodies in
spite of the entity's unsettling
nightmarish appearance it was just
another day's work for the men assigned
to monitor scp-035
and so they carried on with their daily
routine
everything was going according to plan
until one of the men dr jones began to
behave erratically he demanded that his
fellow scientists leave him alone with
the mask for a while and allow him to
engage in a private conversation with it
it is unknown what exactly the two spoke
about while the other two scientists
were absent as the security footage
captured had no sound however several
minutes into the conversation in the
footage dr jones can be seen dissolving
into a fit of tears
laying on the ground and shaking with
sobs as the mask dispassionately watches
he then climbs onto his knees begging
the mask for something before he
embraces it he holds the mannequin in
his arms for five straight minutes
weeping again before they separate
after this disturbing emotional display
dr jones brought the other scientists
back into the room with him
what happened next is still uncertain
but there are a few things that we know
for sure the other scientists began to
speak with the mask in later interviews
the other scientists were bordering on
incoherent babbling about various
traumas from their lives one repeatedly
referred to a drunk driving accident
where a dear friend was killed and he
was at fault another simply cried out
for his mother again and again whatever
the mask said to them it was enough to
completely destroy their mental health
after the two scientists had been
emotionally devastated by the mask dr
jones escalated the situation further
dr jones removed the mask from the
decaying mannequin body and shocking
everyone who had later reviewed the
security footage placed it onto his own
face once the mask was in place the
security footage ends at the command of
the mask which was now speaking through
dr jones the other two men switched off
all security camera monitoring
scp-035's containment facility
the mask piloting the body of dr jones
like a horrible fleshy puppet made its
way through the facility avoiding
detection until it reached the exit
doors
where it was finally stopped by a team
of over a dozen security guards knowing
the dangers of touching the mask all
foundation employees involved in the
recontainment of scp-035 refused to
remove it from dr jones face instead he
was placed in the locker room with the
mask still on left alone to be observed
over the security cameras until his body
had decomposed beyond use
his body paced back and forth in the
cell for days flesh rotting and dropping
away only until sinew and bone remained
only when the bones began to turn black
and brittle crumbling apart into dust
did the body finally stop moving his
family was notified the mask was
carefully removed from what was left of
his body and his remains were destroyed
the other two scientists involved in the
scp-035 escape attempt were terminated
and their files destroyed after this
incident a few more failed escape
attempts and the acknowledgement of the
devastation that could have been caused
if the mask had made its way out into
the general population
scp-035 lost its host privileges all
together several research staff
protested this decision insisting that
there was more to be learned from
speaking with the entity inciting
valuable information that it had given
about other scps however the risk was
determined to considerably outweigh the
potential reward and the requests to
reinstate 035's host privileges were
denied
several staff members went so far as to
erupt into violent outbursts on 035's
behalf attacking their supervisors who
refused to provide the mask with a new
host clawing at them with animalistic
rage
any staff members that submitted a
request to reinstate said privileges
were considered a security threat and
reassigned to a different scp or in some
cases terminated
any staff member who had direct contact
with scp-035 was also terminated in
order to avoid the risk of any more
staff aided escape attempts
the mask is now kept in a hermetically
sealed glass case and there is a
psychologist on call to provide
assistance to anyone guarding it in case
of adverse effects on their mental
health from the mask's presence
personnel that work around the mask even
in its current dormant state experience
frequent violent outbursts and a higher
rate of suicide even without a host the
mask's corrosive effects have spread
across its containment facility the
walls of the room have begun to secrete
the same black liquid that emanates from
the mask which tests have revealed to be
highly contaminated human blood that
damages the structural integrity of the
walls following prolonged contact
this blood has begun to form patterns on
the walls spelling out words and phrases
in italian latin greek and sanskrit as
well as depicting drawings of ritual
sacrifice and mutilation
staff members also report hearing
unintelligible whispering and horrifying
high-pitched laughter when in proximity
to the mask
further exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhaging around the eyes
mouth and nose
and an eventual psychotic brain between
the corrosive substance appearing on the
walls and the physical and psychological
damage to employees
scp-035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are
debates among staff as to whether the
entity can in fact be contained at all
as soon as possible
scp-035 will be moved into a new
containment facility and its previous
cell will be isolated from the rest of
the foundation's property and destroyed
for the safety of all involved we can
only hope that the new containment
procedures are more effective than the
last ones and that this mask never makes
its way into the world again
if it does who knows how many lives it
will claim in the meantime if you ever
come across a strange mask and feel a
nearly uncontrollable urge to put it on
ignore the whispered pleas to just try
it ignore the echoing laughter and the
sensation of something older and more
powerful than you can imagine rummaging
through your deepest darkest secret
thoughts
turn around and run as fast as you can
in the other direction
you'll be glad that you did it's three
am and the facility is quiet office
workers and administrators roam the
halls security officers stand at their
posts clad in advanced tactical armor
and carrying standard issue m4 carbines
three foundation employees sit at
flickering monitors watching a live feed
of footage from the containment cell of
the infamous scp-106
or as it's referred to by all staff the
old man no foundation personnel are
permitted to travel within 60 feet of
the cell for security reasons and nobody
is permitted to physically interact with
the anomaly without the approval of
two-thirds of o5 command the observer's
eyes itch and sting from hours of
unending blue light exposure but they
can't look away the old man is crafty he
might have the insatiable bloodlust of a
hungry great white shark but he's not
mindless he's a calculating predator
more sadistic than the worst human
serial killer and he's always searching
for the next opportunity according to
the foundation records he's been active
since at least world war ii and it's
estimated that he has hundreds if not
thousands of victims to his name and
many of those made simple but extremely
foolish mistakes of underestimating him
after all it only takes a few seconds of
inattentiveness and the briefest moment
of distraction to give him the window he
needs to do what you ask oh don't worry
you'll find out just like they did the
old man has his nickname for a reason
most of the time he really does look
exactly like that an old man or more
specifically an old man's decaying
corpse his body covered in rotten dark
grayish black flesh that looks like
putrid meat though the creature has been
observed being able to change shape the
rod seems to run too deep for the old
man to ever hide it foundation employees
that have observed scp-106 for extended
periods of time have reported seeing it
assume the form of grinning decayed
children and women whose rotted flesh
barely hangs on their creaking bones
just seeing the images through a video
feed is enough to cause a lifetime of
insomnia and other sleeping issues still
they have a job to do and the cameras
remain fixed on the old man he's been
completely motionless for three months
just sitting there like a buddhist monk
in deep meditation a novice might see
this period of inactivity as a cause for
celebration but those with experience
know that this is merely the calm before
the storm scp-106 can remain in a
dormant state for months at a time
described by the foundation scientists
as a lulling state it's believed that
the old man simply waiting for its
captors to get soft make a mistake or
simply have a momentary lapse in
concentration which is all it needs to
make its move it had happened so many
times before and it was about to happen
again one of the observers must have
felt an overwhelming wave of anxiety as
he saw the creature ever so slightly
twitch just a tiny quiver in the
shoulder muscles but that was enough to
tell the observer that their day had
just taken a terrifying turn he grabbed
the emergency phone fixed to his desk
and practically screamed into the
receiver that 106 is moving that they
need a tactical team stat but he was
already too late he and the other two
observers stared into the monitors with
their mouths of gabe as a gooey
rust-like substance began to pool around
the creature on the floor of its cell
slowly the creature craned its withered
neck around its face was fixed into a
broad yellow-toothed lipless grin its
eyes had the kind of dull flat malice of
an underwater predator it looked
directly into the camera directly at
them and smiled the observers knew this
was bad really really bad with what they
could have sworn was a little nod the
old man began sinking into the rusty
puddle it made on the ground beneath it
until it had disappeared entirely
scp-106 is capable of phasing through
any solid surface with ease making it
one of the hardest entities to reliably
contain and earning it a spot on the
dreaded keter class reserved for the
anomalies that are complete nightmares
to keep locked up through the years of
costly research and deadly trial and
error the foundation would later devise
ways of at least slowing the creature
down it's shown to have an aversion to
lead highly complex or random physical
structures and intense bright light none
of these cause harm to the creature as
far as we know literally nothing can but
they'll at least buy you some precious
extra seconds with which to at least try
and escape seconds the three observers
didn't have one of them grabbed an
emergency line again and barked into it
that they lost visual on the anomaly
just then the observers heard a faint
crackling sound behind them and the
hissing of a chemical burn they turned
in horror to see a huge rusty burn mark
expanding across the wall right next to
the door which was their only escape
route they backed as far away from the
doors they could as a rotten hand began
reaching out of the mass of corrosive
black sludge followed by the grinning
face of scp-106 ready to have some fun
meanwhile two heavily armed security
officers agents goodwin and resnick came
charging down the corridor toward the
observation rooms it became a bleak
slogan during scp-106 escape attempts
that all you need to do is follow the
screams and that motto was proven true
that night because awful things were
happening to the observation personnel
they were certainly screaming about it
of course even with the top of the line
firearms there was little they could do
to harm the rampaging old man he seemed
immune to all forms of physical damage
all they could hope to do was keep the
thing distracted until the scientists
and containment specialists finished the
preparations to lure him back into his
containment cell goodwin surged forward
while resnick covered his six vigilance
was key as unlike a standard human
combatant scp-106 could attack from
literally any angle including above or
below physical obstacles were irrelevant
to him and no cover was safe the
hardened security officers could see the
burn mark on the wall of the observation
room as they approached scp-106 was
perpetually coated in a thick black
mucus with powerful corrosive properties
that left any surfaces it touched
permanently marked foundation scientists
speculated that this mucus served as a
kind of pre-digestive substance that
tenderizes meat and bone alike but to
what purpose this serves is a mystery as
the old man has never been observed
eating it's postulated that the only
purpose is causing additional pain
goodwin and resnick knew to treat this
hissing sludge as a potential threat as
the corrosive properties would remain
active for as much as six hours before
finally fizzling out the two officers
shared a quiet nod before goodwin
breached the observation room door with
a hard kick the two of them searched
inside guns at the ready in their time
working at the foundation they'd seen
some truly horrific sights from the
mutilation of d-class personnel
typically death row prison inmates
brought in for use as scp guinea pigs to
the violence and mayhem of a containment
breach but there was nothing in their
past that would ever make the horrifying
sight they saw in the observation room
that night feel normal all three
observers were dead almost nothing
remained of two of them and the third
while still intact no longer looked
human he looked like he'd somehow been
dead a hundred years in the brief period
that the old man had been free his skin
was gray and completely dried out and
his mouth was locked into a perpetual
scream it was a massacre but there was
no sign of the old man goodwin grabbed
his radio and whispered this is goodwin
in observation room 6 requesting
immediate backup we have no idea where
this thing but his sentence was cut off
by a sudden scream from agent resnick
scp foundation security officers are as
tough as nails the best of the best you
might say recruited from the top
military organizations in the world so
hearing one of them scream in fright is
a rare if not impossible occurrence but
even they were forced to yell out in
fear when they looked up to see the old
man standing on the ceiling grinning
down at them resnick raised his m4 and
shot a three-round burst at center mass
scp-106 didn't care even under sustained
gunfire from the two security officers
it didn't flinch the old man simply
reached down and snatched agent resnick
from the ground like it was picking an
apple from a tree the old man held
resnick in one hand and pounded its
other rotten fist into the agent's body
breaking all of his bones resnik
screamed for his partner to help him but
there was no time before goodwin could
do anything scp-106 began receding back
into another slimy burn mark on the wall
only this time he was taking his
screaming victim with him agent resnick
gave one more horrified scream before he
was pulled backward into the inky
darkness leaving the room silent except
for the burning hiss of the corrosive
goo left behind you might think this
would be the end of it but no for poor
agent resnick the worst was yet to come
he was being dragged into what the scp
foundation scientists refer to as the
old man's pocket dimension a miniature
layer of reality within our own where
the malicious scp is essentially a cool
all-powerful god according to witness
reports extracted from victims who were
taken to this little nightmare realm the
dimension resembles a series of twisting
endless corridors where the old man
stalks and tortures his captured victims
to the breaking point manipulating space
and time to his own sadistic ends on
rare occasions the scp will even release
its victims just for the joy of hunting
capturing and torturing them all over
again while agent resnick was learning
the true meaning of terror containment
specialists were mobilizing in itself
preparing the one known tried and true
method of luring the old man back
tempting it with the prospect of causing
even more suffering in order to do this
foundation personnel take one of the
aforementioned class-d personnel and
begin inducing extreme pain by breaking
a major bone or slicing a tendon every
20 minutes the victim's agonizing
screams are then played over the
facility's intercom acting as bait for
the pain-loving old man the screams echo
through the facility's otherwise silent
halls as the mutilated corpse of agent
resnick falls from a new scorch mark on
the ceiling the old man can hear the
sounds of suffering ringing out through
the air around him and he can barely
contain his excitement over the prospect
of a new play thing the snapped femurs
the torn achilles tendons it was all too
good to miss having had its twisted fun
with the security officers and observers
scp-106 wandered back to its containment
cell where a new screaming victim
awaited the other security officers
containment specialists and scientists
evacuated the area leaving the old man
alone with his prey while the
unfortunate class d was left to his fate
the rest of the staff commenced cleanup
procedures which mainly involve wiping
the brown and black mucus from the walls
it would probably be at least another
month before anything like this happened
again and new personnel would be
transferred over to the facility to
replace the fallen all in all just
another night at the scp foundation
scp-682 must be destroyed as soon as
possible
so begins the scp foundation file on the
dreaded scp-682
a highly intelligent reptilian monster
that has despite the foundation's best
efforts proved impossible to kill it may
not be the most dangerous scp out there
considering that some are capable of
eliminating entire realities but it's
one of the most iconic and you've
probably heard tales of the monster that
death forgot and you know exactly why
everyone is so afraid of the so-called
hard to kill reptile it's been subjected
to some of the most deadly weapons and
traps the foundation could devise and
survived attacks from some of its
deadliest fellow scps but before we tell
you about the foundation's many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard-to-kill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about scp-682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead
unlike some other creatures like
scp-096 and scp-173
which are murderous but exhibit no real
higher processing skills
scp-682 possesses cunning advanced
reasoning and even human level logical
intelligence
scp-682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage stay where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset
and the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli
682 is a reactive being capable of not
only surviving and regenerating from all
attacks
but often incorporating those attacks
into its own wide arsenal in other words
if you're hoping to kill this thing you
better kill it on the first hit
because if you don't you better believe
it's gonna hit you back a hundred times
harder
this brings us to the main event some of
the scp foundation's most ambitious and
frightening attempts to terminate
scp-682
or even understand how it could
theoretically be terminated
there are quite literally too many
unsuccessful attempts for us to list
them all here so think of this as a
highlight reel of the foundation's most
prominent failures 682 was first cross
tested with scp-017
a humanoid shadow entity shown to be
able to consume matter with its shadows
and leave no traces behind tests on
tissue samples from 682 showed that
scp-017 was able to consume said tissues
with no adverse effects
however when scp-017 was placed into the
containment chamber with the actual
creature 682 let out a horrific roar
that was so loud it damaged nearby audio
equipment
scp-017 fled to the corner of the room
and 682 in its rage state attempted to
breach containment
agents managed to suppress and remove
the creature but no meaningful damage
was logged attempt failed
scp-173 the killer statue was later
brought in hoping that it's thus far
impeccable track record for killing
would hold strong the second that 173
was introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over six
hours as 682 stared at 173 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682's eyes with high
caliber sniper rifles breaking the line
of sight and causing 173 to attack
though 682 sustained damage to several
parts of its body while its eyes were
generated the creature was not killed it
then regenerated a number of eyes all
over its body covered in a clear armored
carapace that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
perpetual eye contact 173 was eventually
removed from the containment unit and
the mission was aborted attempt failed
in their desperation the scp foundation
restored to bringing in another
dangerous and seemingly unkillable
monster to take on 682
scp-096 also known as the shy guy as
astute scp fans will already know this
being kills anything that sees its face
with no known exceptions and when it
enters its attack mode it's thought to
be quite literally unstoppable
or at least it was while scp-096 was
able to destroy 85 of 682's original
body mass during their 27-hour battle
it was left mentally broken wounded and
huddled in the corner to this day if
ever confronted with scp-682 the shy guy
reacts in pure terror turning away and
clawing at its own face
attempt
failed
during a deadly containment breach
scp-682 also went head-to-head
organically with another iconic scp hall
of famer scp-106
also known as the old man the old man
and a shape-shifting psionic anomaly
known as scp-953
broke into 682's containment cell the
old man pulled both of his fellow
anomalous combatants into his pocket
dimension to continue the battle on his
terms however despite losing 67 percent
of his body mass during the ensuing
pocket dimension showdown 682 still
prevailed with the old man eventually
fleeing back to his cell and 953 being
collected and taken away by agents once
again
scp-682 continued to hold the title but
it wasn't just cross-testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the scp
foundation's quest to kill 682 led them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success
due to scp-682's highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the outset for example launching a
powerful thermonuclear missile at the
creature was soundly rejected by o5
command on the premise that if the
creature wasn't destroyed and evolved to
the point where it could shrug off nukes
humanity would be pretty much done for
other ideas were abandoned just for
being too ridiculous such as one
researcher's suggestion to fly the
creature through the air and drop it
from a considerable height hoping to
kill it with a high altitude impact i'm
not sure we even need to tell you why
that's a terrible idea but during the
experiments on scp-682 the studies range
from honest to incompetent to
straight-up evil
one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for a
sadistic behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct
after all the foundation is meant to be
cold not cruel it was scp-682 that had
the monopoly on cruelty the medic kill
agents were a resounding failure they
attempted to dismember 682 with a
powerful laser only to have the creature
develop reflective services that
displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around
it they attempted to kill the creature
by sucking all the air out of its
containment facility and create a vacuum
but it expelled a dangerous gaseous
compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again
introduced into the room the foundation
used high-precision blades to slice
scp-682 into approximately 12 000 pieces
then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12 000 pieces
reformed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know and fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded itself by developing a second
car pace composed of solid helium when
personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carapace into
deadly shards that fired around the room
and shredded all foundation personnel in
attendance
it had set a trap and that trap had been
wildly successful the creature's ability
to adapt to seemingly any offense is
unparalleled to the point where
foundation staff have no idea how to
classify this creature whether it's
organic inorganic or even alive at all
based on any definitions we could
understand
at every turn the creature just raised
more questions what is it is it possible
to destroy it at all by any means who
was even trying to kill who here
because it certainly seemed like scp-682
had a masterful kd ratio by now more
extreme feats of cross testing continued
in the foundation's growing desperation
to eliminate this monster
scp-162 which is a hypnotic ball of
sharp objects hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682's
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs
however 682 was still able to breach
containment kill 11 people and badly
wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
guardian one of the proposals for
scp-001
the guardian had a flaming sword hotter
than the sun capable of destroying its
targets on an atomic level naturally
scp-682 survived and regenerated perhaps
the most fascinating cross-test of all
was between 682 and
scp-053
who manifests as a kind innocent little
girl with the unfortunate condition of
causing homicidal tendencies in all who
come into contact with her for more than
10 minutes
the people with these tendencies would
then attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researcher's
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage state attacked
053 and died for good and the realistic
outcome in which 682 attacks 053
possibly experiencing some minor injury
or nothing at all and 053 had to be
removed from the containment cell
but that didn't happen what did occur
was considerably more shocking than any
kind of violence when 053 entered 682's
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying immortal mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out zero five three
even appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a single
act in defiance of everything they
thought they knew when foundation
personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards 053 also wept
sat at being separated from her new
friend
to this day despite further testing the
foundation has no idea how or why this
happened like many details surrounding
scp-682
it shrouded in deeply frustrating
mystery
and so the tale of scp-682 continues in
spite of the foundation's best efforts
the monster continues to breach
containment and slaughter with some
regularity taking out its seemingly
limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath
nobody knows where exactly the creature
is from what its true nature is or why
its ability to adapt and regenerate far
exceeds any known organism on this
planet perhaps one day through enough
research and cross testing we can
someday answer these questions with
scientific precision but until then
we only have one answer
hatred
never dies
almost all cross testing to kill or
pacify scp-682 had failed miserably it
faced the gate guardian an scp with a
flaming sword hotter than the sun
capable of tearing your atoms to shreds
and came out fine in its face off with a
horrifying scp-096
also known as the shy guy it broke the
shy guy's mind and reduced it to
jibbering despair even as cps with
supposedly unlimited powers simply
refused to engage the beast in combat so
when it was proposed that they test 682
with scp-999
a creature known among foundation staff
as the tickle monster the idea was
considered laughable 682 had been burned
suffocated cut up incinerated and
growled in the faces of the gods how
could this so-called tickle monster ever
hope to survive an encounter let alone
win a fight
some even believe that this was the last
we'd see of scp-999
but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out as you'll soon discover
scp-999 is an amazing and unique scp in
and of itself
but its secret origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the scp universe are what
make this humble slimy creature beyond
extraordinary
prepare yourself for the heartwarming
yes you heard that right the
heartwarming story of scp-999
several highly trained agents on 682
detail placed 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 pounds scp-999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity
it was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past caused minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long-lasting damage of
any kind to a living thing even its diet
consists only of candy and sweets with a
particular preference for m m's and
necco wafers it consumes these treats
through the cell membrane of its slimy
body much like an amoeba this extremely
stretchy membrane means the creature is
highly malleable including the ability
to stretch and flatten itself out to a
mere two centimeters thick at rest the
creature takes a dome-like shape around
two meters wide and one meter in height
the closest things the creature has to
limbs are prehenso pseudopods those are
the arm-like projections normally seen
on single-celled organisms of which it
has at least three
the more you hear about this utterly
harmless creature the more that matching
it up with the pure embodiment of
absolute hatred known as scp-682 feels
downright cruel in absolute contrast to
the misanthropic attitudes of the
reptile 999 loves humans it has a
playful dog-like attitude much like an
over-excited puppy when approached 999
will react with extreme joy and slither
towards the nearest person in order to
interact it will leap onto them using
two of its three prehensile pseudopods
to hug the person while the third
nuzzles the person's face emitting
high-pitched cooing and gurgling noises
throughout the creature is apparently
pleasant in every conceivable fashion as
even its odor has been reported to smell
just like the favorite scent of whoever
is smelling it examples have included
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
play-doh
it's almost impossible to oversell just
how beloved and benevolent this strange
creature is it's one of the rare sapient
scps to earn the safe class and it's
allowed to roam freely around its
facility at all times apart from a one
hour bedtime period between 8 and 9 pm
in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of dog-like apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with the
creature was the time someone
accidentally fed it a can of caffeinated
cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full recovery
but what would happen when this
whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered monster the employees
observing the test watched in suspense
as 999 began to enthusiastically slither
towards 682 it's no surprise that after
being tortured and almost killed
hundreds of times during testing 682 had
grown jaded to the cross test it was
regularly subjected to when it saw this
strange orange blob squelching across
the ground towards it it sighed and
groaned expecting the worst what is that
the creature asked of its gelatinous
guest
scp-999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitched squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682's
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682's acid eaten face began to slowly
change
it was beginning to smile observers
recorded a noise what they thought could
have been a chuckle as the creature
growled and said
what is this
i feel
good
while the observers looked on stunned at
what was happening 999 began to slither
and crawl up from between 682's toes
reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the
neck there it began to nuzzle like it
had never nuzzled before
the results spoke for themselves 682 was
grinning and chuckling repeating a
phrase that the foundation never would
have imagined coming from 682
feel so
happy
happy
happy
happy
just when you thought scp-999 couldn't
possibly be more adorable you learn
about its greatest power bringing joy
anyone and anything that comes into
contact with the creature even in
passing will experience a kind of mild
euphoria as once contact with the
creature is prolonged this overwhelming
sense of joy increases and continues
long after you've separated from it
prolonged contact has completely cured
depression anxiety and ptsd along with a
number of other conditions including
rage and antisocial personality
disorders serial killers practically
become saints after coming into
prolonged contact with 999 and in that
moment 682 was no exception and there
truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to scp-999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more
scp-999 also appears to have an innate
sense for those who need its help most
with a particular affection for the hurt
and the unhappy the creature appears to
be a true altruist on a fundamental
level even risking its own safety to
help humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
staff
as a result the creature is pretty much
universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one scp who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that the
observers in attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of uncontrollable
booming laughter
it rolled onto its back slamming its
huge tail against the door it had just
fallen victim to one of 999's favorite
pastimes tickle fights hence how it
earned its tickle monster nickname among
staff
the tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep with a
smile still on its face
after 15 minutes of inactivity two
d-class personnel were commanded to
enter and retrieve scp-999 from the
containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 roused from its lumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent rampage
however in spite of this 999 showed no
fear and helped save some of the
bystanders as security officers subdued
and recaptured 682 and even after all of
this 999 showed no hard feelings towards
682 and indicated a desire to play again
it's a creature whose capacity for love
is so limitless that it's practically
immune to fear which is all well and
good because the true enemy that 999 is
destined to face is infinitely more
powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be
what is this monster and why should 999
have to face it someday the answers to
these questions all lie in the true
origins of
scp-999 available only to those with
level 5 clearance and beyond
it's a perfect example of how something
good can come from the darkest places
there would be no scp-999 without
scp-231-7
scp-231 was a collection of seven girls
all impregnated by horrific nightmares
in a ritual performed by a cult known as
the children of the scarlet king
each of these girls over the years that
followed gave birth to some of the most
horrific monsters imaginable
one of which according to some was
scp-682
these beings were manifested by the
scarlet king a powerful interdimensional
nightmare god believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within r and many other
dimensions foundation higher-ups have
declared the scarlet king to be the
greatest existing threat to the
multiverse at large
and
scp-231 was his latest direct
interaction with our universe
the only surviving member of scp-231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to scp-999
a being of pure goodness
that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest scp of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark god of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that
the creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments
scp-999 was making positive changes to
the world around it and according to
ancient texts from a scarlet king
aligned culture known as the devas
scp-999 is still very much in its
infancy yet it already has the power to
pacify its monstrous siblings like the
aforementioned 682
it's believed according to some
prophecies and foundation theories that
the power of scp-999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day 999 will grow
powerful enough to overthrow not only
its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable scarlet king
himself
not through violence or hate but through
the pure force of happiness and love
burning out the darkness and purifying
the corrupted
while the humble scp-999 rarely
outshines its frightening competitors to
those truly in the know 999 is one of
the most powerful and valuable scps in
existence
and may be the greatest asset in the
foundation's arsenal for the war against
dangerous anomalous activity after all
what could strike more fear into their
hearts than the knowledge that it might
be love rather than firepower that
finally dethrones the scarlet king
and for the knowledge that it may one
day save everything we know from a fate
so much worse than death with nothing
but affection for everyone and
everything it's worth offering thanks to
the little orange blob or at least an
extra pack of m ms before bedtime